je speechless et cette fois c'est le
match entre nanas d'agde ni des yvelines
accroche donc toutes les deux des très
fort jose l'une dahlab croit la seule
grand maître vraiment américaine qui
n'est pas enfin d'origine américaine
maison c'est la seule le grand maître et
l'autre c'est une semaine très fort 12
géorgienne donc ça sera un match très
intéressant à suivre donc là ils en sont
la première partie et voilà donc poumon
c'est un conte l'ouverture mais je
dirais que c'était peut-être déjà un
petit avantage pour les north il ya des
dépouilles du genre qui avalait hashtag
peut être même sacrifié le pion décide
c'est un souci parce qu'il y aura
peut-être f5 qui va arriver
donc même ça ça a l'air pas mal ou alors
d'abord défendre d'abord défendre le le
pion et après aller faire des coups
offensifs
donc voilà donc la réfléchit beaucoup
mais sur la paire ça va mettre déjà
réfléchi à main oui donc elle a choisi
de défendre le pion c'est assez logique
et il va essayer de faire des cavs ayach
un cap
cavalli est simple c'est peut-être
possible mais ça ça parait grand chose
du mois parce que la carie il aura pas
trop d'objectifs en restant un bon mais
faire cavalier h5
ou alors peut-être c4 etc a laissé cinq
si on arrive à le préparer sous ces
quatre fous prendre cavalli prompt à f
prend dames feront si le four bien à eux
deux il y aura d'un projet 2,6 à se
trouve ça peut marcher parce qu'il ya
pas à cause du claj avant qu'il a fait
elle l'a fait du coup ça a l'air de
marcher c'est vraiment joli coup sa c4 à
leurs souhaits du coup on a dit sur vous
prendrez qu'elle est pour 84 d'avant et
après mon projet 2 ou alors on prend le
point en c4
du coup ça va faire rêver son adversaire
y réfléchit donc affiché beaucoup c'est
vrai qu'il ait pas deux ont très
longuement la foudre à la limite le drap
qui je passe des trucs du genre fou au
food ayant essaie de sortir le cavalier
ouais c'est pas ta poussa pas top
surtout dans tous les cas il y aura
quasi certain qu'il va arriver
peut-être peut-être cap et bep 3 aussi
ou alors simplement garder cabaye a
essayé d'améliorer la police
bon du coup il réfléchit beaucoup elle
essaie de se sortir de cette situation
elle aura du mal dont camille h3 son but
c'est de faire petit rock bien sûr est
ce qu'elle pourra faire ça c'est la
question parce que peut-être y aura des
cas réveillés pour leucate sacrifice qui
va permettre honneur d'éviter le rock
que y'aura fou prend il y aura d'amour
et de le [ __ ] se rend leurs dons
cavalli pour quatre salaires pas mal ici
ça va vraiment intéressant parce que du
coup sûr f prendre now prend 1,4 y'a pas
moyen de vraiment de défendre ses pions
en g2 pour bouger le roi peut-être mais
du coup il y aura peut-être des défauts
prend 2,5 mois non vous prendrez semble
salaire trop ça l'a vraiment trop c est
ce qu on peut même reprendre avec le
cavalier en fait recaler prendre un 4è
francs et reprendrait que cavalier ok
donc l'adversaire à l'ajout au québec
donc la salle de réfléchir et réfugiés
toujours depuis très longtemps
d'ailleurs
ok donc l a fait c 3 c'est bizarre ça je
vois pas trop ce sont des tac a vu juste
faire cailler prend d'un préfère x 6 mai
mais du coup le roi il aurait attendre
se cacher en effet sa pas trop de temps
ce c'est trop pascoe est du coup comment
on a dit si le temps qu'elle fasse ce
qu'elle éprouvait 4f rende enfin le roi
aura autant de bougies du coup voilà si
ça sera plus possible si son but c'est
d'ouvrir la diagonale c'est un but trop
lent pour ça
ou alors peut-être qu'elle veut faire un
juste faire des tours ces 8es après
cavaillac avec mesa pas trop trop de
sang sont plus à peut-être qu'elle veut
faire cailler prend 1,4 m
bancal et promeut cadrée après reprendre
en cas avec le cahier en c3 ouais
c'était sain je pense quand on lutte
bonjour alex
bondoukou n'a pas pris avec la avec le
pion l'a fait avec l'adoption ce qui est
logique
pour éviter cette erreur parce ceux qui
seraient passés sur sa du coup sûr que
les ponts sur quel point il y aura
sûrement dames et trois ans elle peut
défendre comme ça dames 3e cas je pense
que c'était un peu mieux quand même
parce que ça regardait les options 2 x 6
et surtout sa carte la nada main c'est
un peu plus active vu que la dame
attaqué directement le faut alors
qu'avec le cavalier du coup elle peut
dépasser ce cap
bon alors
donc sur calais prend les 3 bien sûr le
seul coup c'est de prendre cette photo
au poing après la reprise en g3 fois
this on le dirait tout des deux tours 8
et il y a cavaillé géant kaberle 4 ça
marcherait pas parce qu'il y aurait eu
j'ai simplement que le cahier obligé de
se cacher pour le faire donc le thème
pays d'amérique c'est bien vu donc ces
attaques le pion b2 mais du coup c'est
pas si simple de gagner dans c'est
clairement une bonne position pour les
normes mais c'est pas si simple
il ya quand même des mailles de défense
pour les blancs
bon du coup alors peut-être qu'on peut
prendre au g3 et après sur baiia sur sur
plusieurs d'incroyables sont fait juste
note
du coup en france j'ai trois je pense
que le seul coup sa salle de repos avec
le cul parce que sur d'emprunt il y
aurait d'un prendre b2 et le fousseret
en l'air donc niveau
enfin c'est quasiment obligatoire de
prendre avec le cube donc après ça
peut-être d'impôts en banlieue quand
même y aura cavaye f4 j'imagine pour i7
défendre le fouet après cette affair
petit rock et à ce moment-là peut-être
qu'on aura des g5 ou alors des fois ci
ce qui peuvent marcher dès qu'on peut
faire x cse direct en fait mais il y
aura quand même des défenses ike éveillé
4 donc ouais donc là peut-être fou à 6
ça peut être pas mais je pense que ou là
au pied donc elle a pris 1 b 2e donc
c'était mon idée ou là le leur parce que
là du coup si elle prend au moins cela
pour elle elle va avoir des soucis après
deux premiers sets je pense des très
gros soucis surtout que là le cavaly peu
juste défendre le pion qu'on attend
encore un attaquant la tour et après
ouais mais c'est pas top
donc là c'est un gros avantage pour les
blancs déjà parce que nos collègues elle
a pas réussi à regagner son fou de façon
idéale enfin elle a gagné mais pas de
façon idéale du coup un ouais là il y
aura déjà des problèmes donc ça
s'annonce déjà bien ce match pour
pourrir à irin accroche au lieu de
cavaliers jécistes était possible de
faire caler prend le 2 ça ne m'étonne un
peu qu'ils l'aient par des cavaliers
prend surtout prend il y avait tous
rêvent de qui est qui faisait le clouage
mais bon c'est vrai qu'il y aurait 7 6
secondes six secondes ça va être chaud
ça va être chaud surtout que là il ya
des tours 2-2 peut-être qu'il défend la
purge 200 et qui attaquent g2 ouais donc
là on on peut prendre g2 ok donc ça
échange les pièces et après peut-être
vous promet une forme qui va arriver où
là donc la c2
ces deux oeuvres c'est redevenu
davantage pour les noirs donc là le clan
des cinq tombes à tourtour 8 pour
attaquer clary ou alors la menace damas
fasse encore mieux ok donc ok donc bien
joué à dana donc la sauer prend donc d4
ok donc ça simon gambie ou en bus dame
accepté
donc ouais non lâchement ce jeu
souffrant c'est comme ça à l'air d'être
normale mais bon je pense que ça d'appel
à la théorie yolande du coup je puis l'a
pas mais ça fait que je sois moins que
lecavalier vous conseille c'est qassam
avait l'air normal mais je sais pas si
ce qui était la continuation après
peut-être que sur fond prince et kate
aurait eu défaut à six pour essayer de
changer le monde du coup ça m'étonne un
peu qu'elle n'est pas direct je la
trouve c'est une très bonne
salut zig haye a pas eu de type c'est
bizarre toi ah ah oui oui oui
du coup c'est les les horaires sont pas
sans portable j'imagine
du coup là il ya maxime tu vas en même
temps ça occupe du coup
ouais ça va être ça être en très
paisible alors même ans ava ops sort
mais chez qui il est pas top
désolé les gens de l'est entre temps ça
a payé
donc voilà ok là là c'est mieux c'est
mieux on oui seulement alors que se
passe-t-il donc oui donc ça n'a pas
l'air si mal pour les normes est
peut-être celle du couffo bécasseau
c'était peut-être pas meilleure à ça que
ça a l'air bien mais on est quand même
il a elle arrive à le défendre avec à
venir 6 donc je dis bien sûr d'un mac
assure hugues avait hier si ce genre de
choses donc ça vous une fois les as
l'air de rester là pour le moment sur
foix iii il y aurait simplement la prise
et moi c'est déjà un peu la galère pour
les mains
ah oui ok donc
moi je regarderai bien leur stream aussi
je t'aime en train de le faire tout de
suite
alors ouais c'est bizarre je sais pas
enfin ma connexion est normal d'habitude
mais chez toi elle des failles et des
bugs j'espère que c'est pas que c'est
pas trop horrible j'espère que ça va
quand même à peu près parce que du coup
on trouve du coup je ne sais pas trop
comment faire
ah j'ai peut-être changer les paramètres
de sa douleur ça parce que j'avais fait
les deux derniers jours ça marchait bien
donc c'est bizarre bizarre qui a joué
c'est de changer des paramètres
elle a réfléchi pendant tellement
longtemps donc je vais sur ce coup c'est
incroyable
mais c'est en train de les regarder en
bas vous savez mais par contre vous le
dise vous le dites pas une image se fait
5 à 10 secondes
oh c'est moche ça ok bah du coup je vais
essayer de changer ça mais c'est de
faire front je peux pour ça va
bondoukou est là enfin je m'en fous et
là c'est au tour de na na de réfléchir
ni vent sont ces fluides ok bon j'espère
que ce soir il est mis au tombeau
tel que c'est mieux comme ça
attends je vais jouer
bon du coup je reviens juste j'ai c'est
entre eux que je reviens
ok donc bon j'espère que c'est mieux
comme ça
j'ai descendu un peu ok donc ça on peut
me laure hockey même pas encore un goût
amer je parte le monde sa rue à ce
moment là bon bah dis donc
ok donc reprenons donc là je pense
qu'elle est des cats a l'air pas mal
des cartes et leurs biens pour défendre
ses pions ou alors ont des trucs du
genre food et 3 ça marche pas bien sûr
parce qu'il y aura un oeil aux racailles
et b4 donc ça a l'air vraiment très
dense je me sens bien sûr ça ça je pense
que sa part juste ma pièce donc qu'elle
ait des cas je pense qu'il faut vraiment
tenté et sur re5 alors d'être à ce
moment là faire qui avait cinq sur dame
française il y aura un cahier pour les
5es le fou bien sûr défend le cavalier
donc ça a l'air d'aller
donc d'ailleurs c'est la première fois
que je vois autant d'observateurs il ya
210 personnes qui regardent la partie
alors d'habitude il ya toujours maximum
60 parties soixante personnes
enfin sur sur pièce d'un comme
directement donc apparemment c'est un
match qui intéresse les gens c'est cool
210c le mac ce que j'ai vu duke ou away
du coup elle réfléchit encore elle
réfléchit encore bas donc faut vraiment
qu'elle passe cahier des 80 je pense ou
alors faire un truc du genre d'un bep 2
et après sur d'un procès si ça fait un
truc du genre caillet 5 peut-être pour
ouvrir la diagonale du fou et apprécié
rafferty rock
du coup elle a fini faire faire tyrol
donc d'un procès c'est ça marche est
marrant parce qu'il y avait il y avait
qu il ya vait cavaillon 5
et sinon bien sûr des trucs du genre
d'un cavalier 4000 à damas un peu un
besoin de bouger c'est troublant quand
il ya dame peut même bouger avant pour
défendre qu'à 6 5
quel est son but serait d'ailleurs en
être un et trois hommes et trois femmes
j'ai dit tous les toutes les 15 à partir
oui la vie c'est d'ailleurs en b3 caïds
et 4 pour prêt pour empêcher ça mais du
coup il y aura peut-être eu 5
donc là je vois c'est ça
cavale et des 4,5 il y aura peut-être
quelques problèmes sans rancune enfants
et tout repenser 5
donc là géré à nouveau changer les
paramètres dont j'espère que c'est mieux
content dites-moi si samuel 27
donc bon il ya quand même en enfumant
plus pour les noirs et là la tour qui
arrive sur le sur le deuxième rang
cycling donc on va perdre sur mon ouais
donc la toile via le match ouais bon du
coup c'est en rangs partout on partout
donc voyons voir c'est comme ça qu'est
ce que ça donnera ce match va être assez
serré de france
mais bon sur le papier nana est un peu
plus fort je crois mais peut-être
peut-être un blitz fois chez elle est
assez forte aussi
c'est juste à une image au classique
donc avec avec à 3 et après b six
d'entre elles essaient de faire une
espèce de deux fois en français je crois
que ça s'appelle la west indian froid en
anglais c'est queen's en guyane c'est un
peu différent non nous en parlent ils
n'ont pas traduit exactement elle met du
coup assez simple c'est bien bon qu'à
faire des cavs et c'est ici ce monsieur
au lorc avec 17
plus tard il ya plus de pions ya plutôt
de sol et comme ça c'est mieux peut-être
bah dis donc s'il n'ya plus rien qui
marche si à plus en plus l'image que
plus rien
ok donc là on va peut-être essayer de
faire descendre tout tenté de faire ça
ou alors peut-être qu'à u17 8f ça peut
être intéressant
ouais donc là elle a pris vous êtes
prendre avec l'option b way le plan b
pour regarder les options de pousser des
ok je savais qu intéressant donc là-bas
et 17 ou obligatoire pour protéger le
pion d'anne decis ça veut sans intérêts
changent de dames
ouais ça peut vraiment se tenter du coup
même
ouais elle peut pas en finale peut pas
le leur refuser un peut être parce que
du coup si lé ciel après d'un des six et
les retournant 18 par exemple y aura
faut prendre ces cinq qui sont à ma
ceinture a foulé 4 donc ouais donc d'amd
si sa force échange d'armes
après je ne sais pas si c'est forcément
quelque chose que les blancs vol vol
parce que enfin pour que le plan soit 6
5 sera un peu faible on peut dire qu'il
a peut aussi pousser b4
ou alors juste développer ses pièces
dans manon
hu est donc l a fait l affaire donc je
pense que c'est un bon choix au bon sens
pratique par ce feu qui est fait c'est
un bagel qui a team a fait peur quand
même
je me bats je me suis dit ah tout est
possible en même mais je m'y attendrai
un atout ans
donc il y aura peut-être des dés fois
car être des cavaliers centre cabaye et
b6 suivi de cavaillac à ce concile
peut-être maillot qu'aux blancs jouer
donc protect à laquelle a le temps de
mettre son carillon c3 donc disons
cavalier e 2 x 4 leroy bouge
kyle non voilà peut-être tout retour b3
mais du coup il y aura permis aux
cavaliers ces trois oreilles aux
racailles c3 et du coup c'est ça l'enjeu
parce que nous ferons en attaque y en a
quatre y sera attaqué donc vaut mieux
décider de faire le plein de caves et
les baies six cavaliers à 4 donc ouais
donc cavaye de disons qu'elle épaississe
qui a laissé 3 auquel on met 3 mai 3 je
pense que c'est un très mauvais coup
c'est ça donne vraiment une faiblesse
adag b3 ça n'a pas trop de sens du coup
elle a bien fait de doubler les tours
elle va mais c'est un autre tour en b 8
et après il va faire cailler simple je
pense ou alors même temps qu'elle peut
même tenté de faire x 4 ouais donc là ça
a l'air bien ou aussi et peut aussi et
tenter de faire à 5 à 4 ça se trouve
elle va faire ça ou alors même que
simple 4 ya vraiment tous les poussées
qui peuvent arriver là
bon sinon du coup pas le stream ça va ou
esquisse aveugle il ya des lags comment
ça se passe du coup dites moi parce que
moi je peux moi je peux pas trop le
savoir vous me dites aux dons qu'a
choisi le salon c'est bien je pense que
c'est un bon choix pour essayer de
pousser le 4 moi perso j'aurais plutôt
essayer de faire des trucs du genre à 5
à 4 mais m'en fous je pense qu'il ya du
coup son choix un peu mieux donc là elle
va peut-être essayer de faire le 4 mai
sur quatre y aurait peut-être f4
cavaliers g café après l'euro le fou
repartir et ouais kg 4 après le fou va
repartir ou alors peut-être à 5 à ce
moment-là vous pousser tous les pions en
pions c'est pas assez donc key g4 dans
peut-être qu'elle va retourner avec le
faut je me dirais que ce fonds on
aimerait quand même bien le sauver donc
que se passe-t-il sur foot géant ça
c'est la question à un ya peut-être sur
fougères il ya peut-être eu trois en
fait tu es fou prend les trois fous et 4
et ouais ok non elle n'a pas fait ça
donc c'est donc ça la dérange pas de
donner le faut donc bien sûr là je pense
je pense que neuf après ouais ça c'est
logique c'est d'amener un cahier angers
calme et du coup la police est le
empêcher ou alors comme on a fait avec
vous et de aussi ça empêche
ouais donc là à 5 eme clairement faire à
4 donc j'imagine que 1,4 ça serait le
meilleur fou parce que là c'est vrai que
ça que ça affaiblit la case des quatre
n'y a pas vraiment de façon d'y accéder
un mental et en 17 b 8 à 6 et après on
est prêt à les enlever quatre mais ça
prend goût au temps donc c'est pour ça
qu'elle l'a pas fait donc mais je pense
que ce qu'elle a fait c'est bien pu
enfin parce que ce qu'elle a fait sa pub
avec way m cela du coup les noirs sont
souvent bien meilleurs sont bienvenus il
y aura des trucs du genre foule toujours
à 6
ouais ou tour à 8 oui c'est à lire et
d'aliens eu 30 ans à 3 peut-être aussi
cavalier g4 si jamais le faux bouge mais
bon du coup le fond bougera pas donc
faut prendre cahier décamètres il se
passer
cadets 4 je pense que les changes des
tours ça serait pas en la faveur des
noirs donc oui il vaut mieux bouger la
tour peut-être en a deux ou alors la
ramener à la maison à 8
a serious à la connexion et tous ces
tops vraiment ou alors tu dis ça
j'espère qu'un futur
peut-être tour à deux mais réfléchi
qu'avec beaucoup faudrait qu'à mon avis
il faudrait qu'elle joue vite comme ça
pour prendre avantage du fait que crash
est plus que 18 secondes à la demande ou
si elle vous vite maintenant ça la seule
à vraiment ça fera stressé croche
ok elle est fille vraiment beaucoup
j'espère qu'elle va pas prendre et 3
parce que ça a pas vraiment de sens donc
là le choix c'est vraiment retour à 2 et
3 8
les deux sont bons mais je pense que
tout radès et quand même tour à deux
c'est quand même préférable
après qu'elle pense aussi à tour a en
fait ok attendent beaucoup de ce qui
s'est passé là à l'april repris et tout
tourne bien ok elles sont je vais
tellement envie de ces coups là c'était
déprimant où je pense
ouais donc ça c'est d'un mois jusqu'à la
fin parce que du coup ça à échanger vos
côtés c'est ça va être presque est nul
donc elle a vu cette idée avait calé
j'ai quatre maps et roi des deux il n'y
a pas vraiment pas son contenu sur
cavaliers prend h2o mon avis ouais mon
avis le turrialba tomber donc là il vaut
mieux qu'elle défende ses pions et c'est
ce qu'elle a fait mais du coup fossé de
ou la fausse et de ces dangereux l'a
poussé deux tours point a et du coup là
ouais bah tout objet de partir et il
n'aura bon là le client et kateri tombe
ouais donc a vraiment craqué elle a
réaffiché tellement longtemps et la
réparer alors vraiment pas lui échanger
les tours du coup ça ça la mise mal
autant elle a ployé semences et donc
mais rien n'allait oh oh ben non on
signale à nouveau
c'est fou ce qu'il se passe on va plus
en bis
une simple variable donc là c'est nul
c'est totalement nul donc
que couach a à proposer mieux le sénat
n'a utilisé
je passe à bon chat bon dupouey bon
jouer à eve en juillet jusqu'à jamais en
finir au bout enfin donc oui bon c'est
un résultat assez ya assez bizarre puis
du coup j'ai une rivière d'abord c'était
nana qui était qui et équité gagnante et
après c'était c'était irina qu'il était
donc ok donc c'était un bon nul j'aurais
pas vraiment dit que c'était le résultat
pour voler comme on s'y attendait on s'y
attendait pas du tout maman bio coup là
elles reprennent pas ça se trouve c'est
une gamine qui pose c'est que ça se
trouve
peut-être qu'ils posent entre celle là
parce que là ça me fait du coût 35
minutes qu'elles ont commencé à jouer
bon du coup mais en attendant je vais
aller voir des boulistes rime avec avec
mv à dbayé savez que c'est vraiment car
messiaen youku bas merci aux gens qui
regardent du cou qui me regarde moi tu
te de regarder une belle c'est sympa de
votre part du coup c'est la pause on a
vu qu'elles reprennent pas les parties
donc bon pour la petite info youku là
c'est un tournant en fait avec seize
joueuses en tout dont huit qualifiés et
là il y en a déjà eu
je crois c'est ya déjà eu cinq honda
mansat aussi donc ça c'est la sixième
ronde et ce à un système de chaos
en gros donc nos routes donc en gros la
personne qui gagne le match donc là par
exemple simon davies gagne le match
elle réussir à se qualifier pour la
ronde après donc et après c'est toutes
celles qui gagneront leurs matchs non
joués en entre entre elles voilà donc
c'est ça le format donc ça c'est cool et
j'aime bien aussi la cadence en fait
enfin le format de décadence donc en
gros au début il ya je crois que c'est
une heure quinze mineurs 15 qui se joue
en blitz 5 + 2 et après ses 3 45 minutes
en bits 3 puis le 2 mai après à la fin
c'est peut-être une demi-heure en bullet
donc c'est assez intéressant ça c'est
cool de voir toutes les différentes
cadencé aussi c'est bien du coup parce
qu'on peut voir lesquels joueuses quelle
joueuse préférée quelle cadence et y en
a des qui sont vraiment super forte en
certaine cadence et d'autres comme on a
vu hier donc là par exemple le match
d'hier s'il y en ait certains d'entre
vous qui avez qui avait suivi un peu
c'était à c'était c'était pas si c'était
pas dû vraiment en gros show parce que
celle qui a gagné a gagné 16 6 donc on
n'y avait pas trop de suspense
y'avait pas trouve suspens mais oui mais
du coup c'était quand même assez
intéressant de voir les parties surtout
avant les images d'avant
c'était cool parce que c'était vraiment
il y avait du suspense jusqu'au bout
il y avait des départs tard je peux en
30 minutes en plus à la fin dans des
matchs donc ouais donc espérons que cela
serait aussi un bon match donc j'espère
qu'un peu plus de suspense
parce que s'il y en a une qui a plus
vraiment renforce plus comparé à l'autre
c'est pas marrant donc voila mon gas
perdre et non ça va reprendre bientôt je
pense ça va reprendre bientôt mieux en
attendant je me vais boire de fumer bord
de l'eau etc que de l'eau ne
makam bug c'est pas normal non ben c'est
pas très normal non bon bah du coup je
pense que j'ai des prix qu'on attendait
de lui et ses deux balles du couple luxe
et la pause j'ai essayé de changer ça on
en est paramètres si je peux vu que vu
qu'on paie rien je veux qu'on paie rien
n'y a pas de partie
ah je crois que j'ai capté comment faire
ou peut-être parlons maintenant de ne
pas capter pas
monde où l on doit parapher c'est
bizarre beaucoup laissé une grosse pause
alors en attendant je vais essayer de
voir comment je ferais comment je ferais
tu es mon avis
ça y est ça remplit assez cool ça
ça a repris donc on va regarder ça
bon je vais juste un truc et je regarde
tout de suite
donc je suis de retour et bon j'espère
que ça que ça marche bien et du coup
elles en sont à la nouvelle partie donc
c'était en gambie camby d'un accepté
donc ok avec france et 4 way logique
donc ok donc c'est une partie assez
ouverte n'y a pas de y'a pas pu entendre
en tout papa n'en passe pas sur la
colonne s'est aidé ce qu'on a l'habitude
de voir on a toujours l'habitude de
venturi qui ont envie d'aller en d4 mais
là du coup il y en a pas mais en plus on
fait bloc b 3 aussi des petites cases
peut être qu une colique avec nord
peuvent utiliser
ouais je dirais même mettre ce qu'avait
l'élan card que d'autres
non bien sûr tout votre retour 6 1 pour
empêcher qu'ils essaient 308 toi on va
voir les deux tours qui se regarde comme
ça donc
voilà donc comment coup comme dam de mon
amour a bien fermé
la dame est quand même bien pour
défendre ce pion b3 a priori rien qui se
passe sur des a priori savoir mais
peut-être que dans le futur il y aura
peut-être des 206 mon arrivée 5,6 et si
tu arrives à chasser le cavalier qui
après il y aura quelques premiers
transas sera très moche ouais donc dame
eu deux fois foulé pièce peut-être pour
attaquer le cas veille des 4 way du coup
c'est je pense que ça a vraiment fait
ses gammes et deux fois ci ça serait
très dommage
très moche ouais bon du coup on
peut-être dans ces deux ans faute
cette dame c'est 2 mais j'ai vraiment
pas envie de faire ce que vous m la dame
sur la même sur les mêmes colonnes que
la tour c'est ouais c'est pas vraiment
l'idéal bouteilles en plus tu aurais y
aurait des fois ci suivie de cavaliers
3,4 plus tard pour mettre la pression
sur le plus sur le cas veille c4 aux
îles anglais a tenté mais j'ai trois
c'est bizarre donc elle veut faire un
flan cadeaux donc c'est assez bizarre
surtout que cole al le firent hôpitaux
ne sera pas vraiment très fort surtout
adjoint jean bessette donc l'homme qui
veut faire fougue et 2006 et je vois ça
me paraît un peu ample risqué voilà
surtout playa veille avaient l'option
qui arrivait on risque donc de 4 que
faire là dessus
peut-être même cabaye et ses trois
enfants soir faut prendre des prendre
tout reprend après faut prendre des 4 du
coup il ya peut-être cinq est quasiment
obligatoire encaissé trois peut-être
vous prend b3 et le 5 mai aps le khalife
des champions mais du coup faut prendre
trois mesures d'un problème 3 y aura
d'apprendre des cas du conte sera
obligée de prendre avec le cavally ouest
c'est une grosse l'imsa assez cool ça
c'est ces accidents sont à quel rang
dollar en fait c'est depuis tous que ça
se passe où c'est moi
ouais donc à et c3 comme on a dit on
vous prend b prend et après le 5 et
après il faut prendre trois y aura qu
elle fonde donc je pense c'est ce
qu'elle avait envie terme elle voyait le
coup elle a changé de mains pour prendre
des quatre images in juste fou prend des
quatre on attaque toujours le gagnant
des 5-6 le cavaly bouge pas alors le fou
il sera soit une superbe diagonale
c'est pas vraiment une bonne chose pour
les français
ok donc faut prendre en effet chaque est
d'essayer ce pas ouais ok 10,6 à leur
top 6 la tour bouge alors tout
recommencer 3,6 la tour bouge en
retraite ou alors si la tour bouge en dc
sur 1,5 ce qui est encore mieux ah ouais
c'est mon ordi à ilhem palestri mon ordi
il n'en peut plus
salut xna aux basques des prêts pour des
portes et pavie j'ai pas vu wikipedia
encore j'étais préparé j'imagine tuteur
entraîné toute l'année tout plein toute
la nuit à ivry bout la poupée qui se
passe ici
donc quelle décision prendre ouais donc
on a pris la tour sur un fonds prend les
enfants
alors bon ça a l'air d'être bien on
passe on peut reprendre peut-être et
après prononcé trois et en plus ces
revues que la dame se retrouvera ensuite
ça sera ça sera un clou et on pourra
même faire des 4
à leurs diverses riddick sur coup franc
puis dit que ce fou prend f1 il ya tout
reprend ses trois en pâtit et sur
d'annoncer huit hommes et du coup ça
parle pas de sa forme et ça tombe bien
j'aime à poil ou pour vous donc le juste
aussi en rappant du coup c'est pareil je
juste le maître sur l'échiquier qui me
disent ah donc tu vois il aime bien
touffu de francs cfa il a changé d'avis
il a vu changer d'avis j'étais en plus
sur fréjus ans parce que ça transposer
au même
donc là c'est gros ou aux avantages
parce que bkc un peu c'est impossible de
le saper
d'imagés figées sérieux balance
bon j'espère que ses revenus
ok non ça a repris donc c'est d'un jus
la même que l'as dahra fin mais l'énorme
enjeu la même avec ab thioub b6 les
plaindre que changer donc bon plat sur
ce que vous prend même si son baluchon à
prendre pour sortir les pièces
tranquille épouse et ses cinq des 5
ça a l'air d'aller donc bon vieux
qu'elle réfléchit je pense qu'il n'a pas
envie de prendre elle va peut-être faire
défaut at 4 et après sur sur fou
bessette chine ou d'inde sera donc ouais
donc j'imagine qu'elle connaît ça ou
parce que c'est derrière c'est un très
bon coup donc j'imagine qu'elle va
connaître ce genre de conte ne fait pas
on ne fait pas juste comme ça mais ça
l'a vraiment toi voilà mettront vraiment
en bon coup donc là les noirs vont être
obligés de faire qu'ils détruisent genre
canet-66 pour attaquer le clan des 4
mais à ce moment là il y aura juste vous
prend et puis c'est après l'échangé on
se retrouve avec des plans doublé ce qui
est pas très bien pour la structure
pas même carrément je m'y attendais pas
ça à ton âme et c'était une grosse gaffe
en fait ce qu'elle appelle c'était juste
une gaffe
du coup la barre être totalement parmi
elle va être entièrement fermé parce que
y'a rien d'un drame sept et il faut à 6
ouais mon bois elle a déjà quasiment
perdu qu elle peut toujours tenter
cavalli f3 aps faire payer 5 mais ça
veut dire ici
est-ce que c'est toujours fidèle est ce
que le son ça va ou alors tout et fut
tout est figé
est ce que vous voyez quand même l'écran
ou à gaz où la caméra
c'était juste me kammer savent à peu
près parce que tant que vous voyez pas
mais les parties et william mabasa mais
m et du coup si tout est figé c'est pas
top donc dame e7 cavaillé l5 qu'elle
prend des quatre murs étant déjà très
apprécié ces deux
tel que je faut que je change si je fais
comme sa déco c'est mieux que je suis
unique mine hautaine
c'est super bien juste en changeant de
la ddt en changeant la scène c'est mieux
de la super offre parce que du coup au
lieu de coolus de 60% de 70% de cpu
maintenant on me dit que j'utilise un
monde 40%
du coup ses comptes du coup là je pense
que c'est réglé
faut juste pas faire que vous voyez des
jouets c'est tout
a donc là donc là dont sur d'improbables
à saint mayme et bien sûr monter en
gamme et donc il vaut mieux faire un
échec d'abord suroît ces deux cas veille
à 5 pour attaquer le pion ses cartes
mais aussi mon âme en garde toujours la
tacc qu'on a sur le sur lequel veilleux
5 donc là je pense qu'il y aura cavani
detroit mais du coup on prend juste en
c4 et en plus sur un peut-être des fous
bessette d'un point à 7 et tout retour à
8 qui gagnent plus
donc moi je ferais bien ça cegetel je
ferai ça assez monde entier surtout
qu'après la comme on a dit la dame sera
sera pas morte disons
donc tu te dis tu en fis championnat
lors de fumer deux parties dos à moi du
coup moi je suis je supporterai pas je
le suis je soutiens moi je filme avait
entre le mot anglais su faire supporter
ces et oui du coup ça veut pas juste je
soutiens danone parce que du coup et des
gens reviennent plus que je vis en
géorgie c'est ça serait cool de lavaur
gagny ah oui non c'est totalement fini
mais hélas hélas hélas elle a le look et
soudan alors dû faire qu'avec b 3 mai
après cavalli b5 là c'est pas bon du
tout en fait c'est pas fini du tout du
tout parce que l'ordi dic c'est moi ou
alors - 0.9
alors qu'avant sur camille 3 c'était
moins quatre fois en cinq
c'est quand même beaucoup donc hélas il
a un peu il a un peu loupé scène un peu
gâtées
dame est roi il dit lors d'un bref trois
sur d'improbables 5 prendre en b 5
mais après il dit que hausse et
maintenant il a changé d'avis il y même
que c'est moins 0.3 seulement wayne on
s'arrête pas puisqu'elle a fait servir
croyait jusque-là faire avec
avec d'un match 3 quoi surtout si elle
connaissait pas je pensais que c'était
peut-être une prépa et qu'elle
connaissait une ligne hyper pointu mais
enfin je sais pas c'est si tu vois
bizarre surtout de fer s'annonce très
compétition aussi importante que ça a
joué des dames et froid ça veut dire
qu'ils connaissaient vraiment rien
l'ouverture
voilà vous avez peut-être vu ça
quelqu'un jouer ça en butte à elle
l'attendait mais du coup du coup c'est
bizarre qui en plus cela il a un café
laférois bien tout donc il y aura
qu'avaient les prend à 3 suivi d'un bain
de sang qui préfèrent les nanas que les
riches bien vivre est les nanas qui sont
les qui sont des cruches alors tu en dis
quoi de ça ouais il faut à fois ci c'est
bien c'est bien et du coup si la dalle
mort par ja non enfin d'abord du coup de
raquette et promis à présent cependant
pressenti
cavaillon chat arrive sa place et ses
jours ouais annoncé qu arrivé 5e c'était
vraiment pas à dubai ou du beau jeu a
beaucoup là et peut même prendre en b2
la préfère payer prend et veut c'est
fini je pense là les banques off 15
quasiment abandonné
donc ça à prier
ok donc gambie dame accepte et on faire
la même qu'avant si à ce qu'ils meurent
encore rejoué kerry et deux bons chevaux
cette carte c'est le pompon rouge aux
joues rémalard ouais tu vois les gens
croient que je veux cahiers du cahier
des deux f 16 sont pour fêter ce qu'ils
avaient tout à fait là d'ailleurs
duke ou peut-être même faire j'ai
parfois trop en fait il ça serait bien
it's now est ce que c'est parfois à 3
est ce que c'est un bon échange entre ce
que du coup ce raté je pense que sa robe
en échangeant potes de faire x 3 mère
violée assure les choeurs d'influencé
sur la même couleur que le fou et en
plus le foulard noir il a l'air pas mal
mais j'ai pas leur disais ça me disait
fort à toi ça me paraissait un peu
bizarre mais je vous sors tes jugements
cette nuit non mais le salon et on a
étouffé tous compris que c'était une
blague inquiète
t'inquiète je comprends ton amour
du coup elle veut prendre ce pion on
irait elle veut prendre ce pion faux
bekaert y aura peut-être mais j'ai
l'impression que laquelle on joue et
c'est en plus cela dérape et après là
j'ai vu à 5
ouais c'est exactement pareil ce qu'il
ya eu un bon père ce que tu vas encore à
donc elles ont rejoué exactement la même
je me rappelle plus du score pas comment
ce que c'était mais bon vu que non a
gagné quasiment tous les partis
je pense que c'est plutôt moins de rêver
non at il également
je crois qu'il ya eu six emplacements je
me rappelle plus haut peut-être c'est ça
qu'il a fait mais bon jouer la même à
chaque fois du coup aussi si toutes les
parties sont comme ça ça fait savais pas
vers votre gros spectacle où on a du
coup les noirs réfléchissent je pense
qu'elle va essayer de changer un peu
bref y aura poker
donc encore une fois lors des dix fois à
3 donc là j'imagine que moi une fois 3
c'est vraiment le meilleur fou parce que
ce faux il est vraiment en battant en
mai 4
faut prendre tout reprend après le pion
c3 va tomber mais web puisqu'une foule
sur quels desseins qui ont quoi pousser
le 4 mais bon même si le pion tombe
c'est pas en si gros problème pour les
points noirs parce qu'ils ont quand même
hmm hmm matin l'oeil d'un enfant tue
c'est pour ça donc même sans le pion
culte ça va quand même s'appuyer sur lui
quand même fait pas approcher noir
donc là j'imagine pour prendre après
faire d'un procès trop joie barande
autre façon continue ce que tu en prends
passion ne sera pas romane
ouais c'est très calme c'est très calme
et 6 nov
du coup tours bénite pour défendre sa
salaire normal un peu peut-être qu'on
peut pousser ses cinq aussi un peu tard
sur ouais mais faut faire tomber du toit
il faut vraiment défendre ce qu'ali ou
alors faire damas est pour défendre
comme ça c'est 5
oui mais du coup sûr c'est simple le cas
il n'est plus défendu c'est un peu
bizarre parce qu'avant moi c'est ça
qu'on en a marre bien faire mais pas
tout de suite si on fait c'est un tout
de suite parce que la prison n'est
obligé de passer un peu de temps à
défendre le cavaly donc c'est un peu on
peut se lancer un peu lent du coup parce
qu'on n'aura pas le temps de faire les
kabyles quatre mois on aimerait bien
faire ou alors d'autres d'autres choses
le coni a obligé de passer un coup à
défendre le cavalier donc ces cinq-là
faut je pense qu'on peut juste prendre
balala l'attenté à l attente est le fils
de ton ennemi historique c'est le
syndrome du coup ce n'était pas vraiment
mon choix
ah ouais ils expliquent n'importe quoi
george aurait dit absolument
ok je vais aller voir ça du coup
samantha laisse juste pour rigoler un
peu mais bon c'est un troll jettera je
vais dire aux serait là elle a raison
c'est super intéressant ce que j là je
me rends compte que je des petits sauts
si wayne on a ça va aller elle joue
vraiment bien je crois enfin c'est m
elle mérite vraiment le coup d'être né
dans d'être dans le top model mais bon
je dis pas ça juste parce que parce que
je la connais bien
bon du coup lallinois ils vont essayer
d'attaquer le lui ont peut-être faire un
tour c'est vite pour essayer d'attaquer
pour prendre oies en est donc là il ya
plus de tours s'est vite bien sûr un
cavalier 17 ouais mais youku d'abord
alors appris en le 2 or on apprend qu'à
et 17 et on peut ramener de l'eau tours
en c1 ça c'est cool ça dans une belle
position pour les blancs seings ouais ça
c'est vraiment super policier
et s'il a besoin d'un monde est de
cacher son roi et que juste maintenant
tour et après m'être en géant facile
tranquille mais c'est même pas renié cet
art qui fut même garder son rang au
centre qu'il n'y a pas trop de menaces
pour le bonjour thiès ça est ce que tu
es prêt à nous parler de d'insectes à
nous
bon du coup elle attaque la dame il y
aura peut-être tour pour ces quatre
jours sega c'est nécessaire je pense
parce que si on remet la dame là il y
aura toujours des huit il y aura pas d
des sous c'est sûr sur b2 donc là je
pense que c'est nécessaire de faire de
faire ça et sa force quasiment les gens
j elle est obligée de faire tous
répondent un prompt et après un qu'avec
deux c'est peu de tout on peut faire
caler bessin et d'un pont d'ain pompéi
prog et phrase est ça à lire ça a l'air
plutôt cool donc et réfléchis tu as
trouvé la foi il bougeait atteint ouais
t'es qu'une envie de vous dit la dame
bah pour lyon il ya que toi dans le chat
en du coup du come on sait pas trop mais
oui si c'est que si c'est que toi et la
three news witz à sa séance en % pour la
promenade du coup du coup bon elle
essayait de faire des trucs comme ça
mais qu'on va simplement en f1 peut-être
aussi poussé trousses et les pions mais
bon on en a qui ont pas assez l'avancé 5
mais c'est pas si simple de réussir à
faire des shows donnés ce moment mais
nos tours le pion à saint lô va tomber
donc ouais à mon avis il vaut mieux
faire beaucoup des changes pour la pour
les blancs et c d'après de 2 pouces et
même où il a peut-être de chasser les
cavaliers avec eux quatre
parce que pour moi c'est pas si simple
enfin je pense que c'est quand même
gagnants pour les biens pour les blancs
bien sûr mais c'est assez simple de
vraiment
ah oui gaiman m un bassin de germes en
fulminant ouais c'était cool ça à la fin
j'ai appris aussi
es tu nous raconter à fraude est de la
délicieuse nourriture nourriture si avec
ça
ainsi cinq secondes cinq secondes pour
pour lire nord mon 18 secondes pour
nanomètres 18 savoir quand même ça
commence à être chaud mais bon du coup
c'est pas si simple
je pense de faire des progrès après si
on arrive à marquer les b sens que ça va
wake a et b 5 c'est madame amon tobin
vous et vous faire quelques baies 5 fois
ok donc elle l'a pas fait bon j'imagine
qu'il lui reste patent à la formiga fait
il ya bien plus qu'à les promesses un
froid au lit tous reprendront donc je
vais y retourner
non il n'y avait pas jusqu'à les
premiers cinq voix alors je dis non
choquer prend d'un proche des six ça a
l'air d'aller
mais bon il a trouvé un truc que j'ai
pas le hockey on continue donc c'est
fini
aïe aïe aïe il ya toujours des
sacrifices façon quoi qu'il arrive y
aura toujours des sacrifices donc n'a
encore gagné
elle a donc quatre et demi avant amy
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une grosse
différence
ouais je me rappellerai si tu nous a
sorti que le seul truc que tu aimais
bien c'était c'était le fromage panais
je crois et en tricot ben ouais c'est
pas trés trés bon sinon un
sisi jadriya de l'agrément il ya 10 à 2
oui je crois ça c'est du simple +23
m'étais comme ça que c'est pas écrit je
moi je
si c'est sa brune blonde s'est pas
beaucoup après ça dépend quel genre de
truc que tu manges
enfin si c'est vrai que les les plats de
viande moi j'aime pas trop beaucoup mais
mes gars quand même beaucoup de beaux
coups de feu de spécialités que j'aime
bien en géorgie en général feront pas
trop d'aidés flahaut viendras par le à
parler les brochettes de kebab ça j'aime
bien mais même et ukulélé ratchaburi les
trucs comme ça ça s'est super bien
qu'alliés mêler les plats de viande dont
jonas est vrai que je n'aime pas trop ça
on peut il ya un peu trop de soucis
aussi le l'avion ne s'est pas trop de
bonne qualité donc ça fait les lyrides
vous choquer a donc atteint un autre
niveau
enfin que moi en tout cas le spectateur
devient possible
ok donc non aux commandes du coup alors
là ça attaque là bas mais on peut être
aussi faut ses dessins dans le futur
c'est ça que les colis nord veulent
faire donc là j'imagine atteint mais
force est de repartir parce que sur fou
prend et fiscales et prend des quatre
faut prendre des huit qui aura payé 2
qui va gagner
donc là la dame est obligé de bouger et
il y aura des 5
donc faut vraiment qu'elle arrête de
jouer cette variante irin accroche ça ça
lui va vraiment pas ce drame ses deux
cela je crois deux parties de suite avec
les blues allaient elles se retrouvent
des super mal super tôt donc ça y va
vraiment pas mon petit changement de
répertoire de répertoire c'est
nécessaire là en plus le pion c4 peut
être fait il y aura peut-être des tours
ces huit cavaliers à saint vougay millau
tiens qu'est pétantes et dam dam des six
mais à ce moment là il y aura 4 4 sur
d'amendés 6 et en plus la rabaudié
survivre café qu'elle écrit quatre ça
marche sur elles feront bien sûr on
prend le pion le le fou en h4
et sinon sur faut prendre des beats on
prend la dame bien sûr et ça a l'air
d'être sacrément gagnon
ouais ça a l'air d'être bassil lefebvre
et va être super bien quoi elle l'a fait
c'est cool donc sa structure depuis on
va se retrouver un bien meilleur il faut
prendre nous faut prendre des huit cas
les pentes aux conduites après la lépi
ont doublé ça va être très moche a donc
ok donc à part pris elle a remis son
foulard c'est un bon choix je pense pour
ici de feu au moins de garder un peu sa
structure à peu près normal donc là
cavalier à quatre c'est possible ou
alors même qu réveil des quatre parce
que sur la plaisir caillé ses deux
essais la fourchette
donc ouais mais bon quand il a capté le
coup le plus normal donc ok ok elle a
fait ça pas mal pas mal pas mal surtout
en bus - et donc elle a vu elle a vu que
lecavalier arrivé à sir facilement à
sortir en mai 3
tours c'est en cavale est à 4 le bleu
pions sera attaquée elle peut même pas
pousser mes trois parce qu'il y aura la
prise terrible terrible
donc là salaires déjà testé la tête
c'est raide mort donc peut-être fou
détroit mais bon il ya quatre ans m
caumont et dia pas b3 donc peut-être b4
et après peut-être qu'on peut faire des
cahiers des deux protêts qu'elle fouille
attaqué plus on sait 4 et après essayer
de faire un tour c'est 8 et aussi mettre
la pression sur le plan de ses quatre ça
peut se demander
bon réfléchir et fléchés la jacking une
minute et demie devant à la pendule
donc elle a tenté de cacher son bras
pour éviter de la fourchette indiquée
ces deux donc bon là je pense que le
mieux c'est juste de remettre le camion
à 4 pas ici de tenter de trucs trop fou
avec un ep 3 parce que la tour se
cacherait en vain
donc ça sert pas à grand chose vaut
mieux juste ramener le cavalier garder
kavian des cartes peut-être poussé le 5
pour mettre la fin pour wayne du coup là
peut pousser un coup alors faire payer 5
plus que s'attaque le faut surtout
reprend 17
elle va faire fouiller 8 pour attaquer
la tour et après va prendre aux riches 5
aurais-je quatre hommes du coup il a
fait le 5 ok donc b5
ouais mais yoku la ffr qui les provoque
allait prendre b2 balle au bond je pense
que c'était assez pas joué de la part de
proches mais est-ce avec la police ont
été assez difficiles valait quand même
qu'elle fasse tout retour des deux pour
défendre ses pions donc là il ya soit
simplement qu'elle est prend b2 qui
gagne à coup sûr je dirais pas ça sur
tours d2 il y aura quelques courses et 4
et surtour béant
je crois quand même qu'il procéderait
sur tours c'est un cahier des trains
tigana tour donc mais qui prend b2 c'est
fini c'est fini je sais pas pour un
réfugié tant que ça en fait à non non je
dis non en fait sur surtout payant il
n'y a pas qu'elle ait pensé qu'à parce
qu'il ya eu des quatre donc surtout bien
elle est obligée de cercueils des trois
échecs et suroît et royal pour pouvoir
amener et ramener kai lan à la maison je
pense ou alors peut-être faire cailler
pts 5
donc le roi se rendait en le 3e sera et
chaque et sa gagnera le fou on échange
des cavaliers qui sera en d3
ou alors vous peut-être juste prendront
cependant eu 2 après revenir avec le
cabinet le kavé qui sera en d3 qu'ils
reviendront c'est un petit don quel
point ces cas ça marche uniquement si
les blancs enfants autour des 2 parce
que là ce moment là la course sera
attaqué sur tourbe et en comment allier
leurs obligés de faire qu'il y ait des
trains y a pas le choix
non faut pas qu'elle gâche est bon je
pense qu'elle l'avait je pense que oui
ce genre de couilles assez simple pour
elle donc pas payées à cannes c'est
bizarre donc cahier à quatre contre moi
et mes cahiers prendre des caps
qu'est-ce qu'elle a prévu le feu avec
john seule option c'est bizarre fois ok
donc elle donne les pions des quatre
hockey ouais bon elle a un peu perdu son
avantage
si à trop belle avait juste part a
calculé qu à vide des trois mais bon
c'est un choix un peu bizarre surtout
qu'elle avait réfléchi pendant là
dessous caillé ces cinq mois on l'a
quand même une bonne position elle peut
pas une terreur nous faut aussi cesser
de pousser des plants mais ou alors
faire doubler les tours mais mais bon ça
me paraît un peu beaucoup beaucoup moins
avantageux qu'avant ouais tour si cela
je pense à préfère tours tours 8
donc il est toujours bon le plan de
gains puisse dire est que c'est surtout
se focaliser sur ses faiblesses pas mais
aussi c'est de rentrer avec les tours
poitiers 6 est le bienvenu pour défendre
ce pion au tour 3 c'est possible ici
pour attaquer le cul aura 3
ok faut à quatre c'est aussi un bon pou
tour 3 arrive quand même faut qu'elle le
voit par contre si le vois pas ça se
remplit plus difficile de faire des
progrès donc elle l'a eue c'est bien
donc ouais comme on a dit on veut faire
ça
pour à deux bras bouge que se passe-t-il
a prononcé cinq les risques de tomber
quand même par le ton s'il coule et donc
ça veut dire quoi ça leur du 3 plus
dehors car les moustiques mais à gsm à
s'aimer bête noire une mystique jésus je
les déteste absolument ca
je pense que c'est la chose que je
déteste le plus y en a des qui ils
étaient ce les serpents ou alors c'est
moi c'est juste les moustiques je sens
que j'ai un peu plus de 2 de ces petites
bestioles
au fossé bah mince hélas hélas total
manga fait à temps il s'est passé quoi
donc doit donc aller à l'essai elle a
laissé pousser ses 5 suivi de celui de
fos et 4 c'est la juste part du feu
faisait assez improbable c'est si vous
êtes toujours ces trois pour empêcher
fossé 4 et l'atteignant à la grosse
gaffe calligraphie ou quoi il parle
elle parle à tour très très moche bon
elle a quand même gros avantage mais est
en fait c'est la pause loin c'est la
pause donc ça reprendra dans sa logique
je pense et ça sera du 3 + 2 donc voilà
donc je vais faire une petite pause moi
aussi et je vous retrouve dans sa
mutuelle points clés des parties
reprendront donc à tout de suite du coup
je vais juste disparaître je vous laisse
à l'échiquier
bon je suis de retour et les parties ont
repris
donc on en est où 11e coup donc voilà le
début ça ça c'est comme ça comme d'hab
comme d'hab mais sauf que cette fois
elle a pris direct elle a fait dire est
qu'il faut prendre ces quatre au lieu de
faire cailler 2 donc elle a changé un
peu salines ouais donc la halle et s'est
rendu compte que ça lui donna pas une
très bonne position
donc c'est un bon choix d'abord changer
de l'année
donc à non j'ai l'impression qu'ils
donnent aussi le jour une partie comme
ça je crois
ou alors un texte à transporter mais
j'ai l'impression que les cendres ont
aussi joué parti comme ça avant
récemment parce que je me rappelle
qu'ils avaient des idées du même style
on pourra opter que je dis non je dis
non mais bon ok du coup là il ya public
des dames des cinq wave 3 clio 4 ok key
des cinq donc que le voeu trompèrent
pour épier j'imagine c'est l'idée
peut-être aussi fois-ci l'instant aucun
pour faire car il prend b3 et c'est
gagné le cavagnan c4
1 alors là il réfléchit donc oui
clairement je crois que tu en avais déjà
eu ce genre de position parce qu'on
pensait adam ii avant n 7 a pas si t'as
pas la même fougue faut que j'arrête de
chercher un rapport sa balle à l'eau
du coup damas deux fois f6 ou alors dame
c2c sur la même qu'on l'a nicolas tour
donc donc on n'aime pas trop
ici il ya peut-être fois à 6 ou alors
peut-être faire fou et merci c'est
essayer de pousser le 5
ça doit sans doute remarqué aussi
alors que s'est-il passé à elle joue
comme avant car avec aline avec lui j'ai
trois ans et vont encore essayer de
cacher s'en fou alors ou alors platnum
kernel foule hommes mais hop et donc
donc apparemment elle avait hélas vu
arriver des salles du coup c'est pour ça
que je veux la même encore donc l'ordi
dit fou prend des 5 mai après faire qu'à
les baisser mais ça me paraît un peu
bizarre de données il faut donc voilà je
pense que c'est mieux ce qu'elle a à
faire sur le sang et or est quasi
absente
vous étiez seul mieux maintien elle a
pris naissance goog et donc je vais
faire qui avait b6 et après reprendre le
fou ça c'est assez logique aussi mais
non ça me fait mal de donner ce flou
angers 2 mais bon du coup vu qu'on
arrive à reprendre le fou le fou de
cases blanches ça va aussi
c'est pas un grand gros son
donc la tour est sans doute obligé de
bouger
j'imagine mais un cavalier en trempettes
câble ah ok donc d'am-dam la tamla ou ok
donc pas la tour déjà la reprise
moi donc c'est 4 d'ailleurs elle aurait
pu le faire car tout de suite je voulais
faire eux quatre ils auraient pu le
faire tout de suite parce que sur fonds
prend il ya d'apprendre après elle peut
prendre
il lui resterait cependant de rester
vraiment du mauvais un time management
17 fois avec 14 secondes où je crois
vraiment pas qu'elle errait qu'elle va
réussir tes deux questions j'ai deux
questions je vois ta question sur la
slave
alors non maintenant en fait non ah j'ai
oublié pas j'ai pas de jegun vous
désolez pendant la prochaine fois je
regarderai alors
mais je pense que j'aurais du mal à
trouver cet impôt sur internet peut-être
je vais moi aussi si cette richissime
mais l'air tu m'as toujours pas dit
alors 7 pourront on l'appelle semi slave
la route du coup c'est quoi alors
pourquoi est ce pourquoi est-ce que s'il
ya ce missile avait slave alors c'est
toi et tu peux me dire ça du coup vu que
je veux que tu connais bien et l'autre
c'était pas voir une question façon
c'était formulée c'était plutôt une tête
ont l'impression à mais oui du coup je
suis aussi d'accord avec ce que tu as
dit sur les sur les échecs féminin enfin
c'est beaucoup du time and est donc
surtout ce qu'on a vu hier avec avec la
les parties de corps à corps il avait du
très mauvais talent management
mais le talent management c'est aussi dû
au au minimum 1 me enfin je veux dire si
la cité ainsi tard mauvais niveau aux
parts égales au site à un niveau
inférieur
forcément tu vas devoir réfléchir
beaucoup plus pour pouvoir trolls et les
coûts du même niveau que ceux de ton
adversaire
donc oui enfin c'est ce fait c'est
surtout le niveau du cou parce que
celles ci les ont besoin de réfléchir
autant ça veut dire qu'elles sont mais
son nom est forte cette fois parce que
ça veut dire
alors sur ma chaîne perso j'ai pas de
stream prévu et en fait j'en faisais
beaucoup j'ai fait beaucoup de janvier à
février mais là j'ai vraiment pas trop
le temps de ce crime et sur moi saumâtre
prochaine ou parce qu'aussi si je me
lance dans le streaming
je devrai faire quasiment tous les jours
passer cinq ou six heures la suisse je
ne peux pas juste pas le faire parce que
je suis coach je fais aussi pas mal de
trucs donc je peux juste pas pas passer
autant de temps à faire du streaming
donc c'est pour ça que je le fais pas
sûr sûr sûr ma chaîne et d'ailleurs je
le faisais quasiment fins exclusivement
en anglais en fait je sens ma prochaine
j'ai jamais fait de ce crime en france
elle je voulais en faire un moment donné
et bien sûr pendant les gens parler en
français je répondais mais s'était
jamais s'était jamais on sent pourtant
français donc [ __ ] aussi je refais si
un jour je joue en fait sur ma chaîne
peux dire est que je le faire en
français du coup peut-être que je vais
je vais tenter ça
à cela slava moitié slave à moitié
non mais tu pas vraiment longtemps
oui non mais ça ça c'est ça oui du coup
je pensais que c'était oui du coup c'est
juste que c'est combien cela vaut mais
çà çà çà et paf ça m'aide pas vrai on a
cherché là donc ici on dit mot alors est
ce grave mais pour eux ce que ça
viendrait du mot esclave en fait pour
être on dit je pensais que c'était
vraiment le coup ça venait enfin de fil
je vis des pays celle alors oui si tout
ça pourrait esclaves
enfin c'est bien de sommes bien deux
c'est quoi l'histoire derrière cette
ouverture
ok du coup il faut quand même commenté
du coup ok donc ça s'était très
symétriques
mais elle vole à prix élevé à 3 à
l'europe renflouement voilà donc le pion
où il sera facilement défendable avec
eux trois ces l'a jamais besoin de le
faire
si l'âme elle a besoin ou alors elles
peuvent aussi faire des trucs du jour
qu'elle veillait 5 pour crier encore
plus de problèmes qu a lieu cinq
salaires pas mal aussi
bourdy aime bien ou alors ouais le 3
c'est le coup le plus le plus solide
mais mes lordi n'aime pas ce qui se
passe après d'un monde et 5
il n'aime pas du tout du côté des mots
donc bon mais bon d'un dessin c'est un
coup très humain donc ça m'étonnerait
qu'elle le loup ouais c'était un peu
c'était logique elle face à un autre
bout donc ok ok là il chasse le fou si
le fauve en hausse il y aura sûrement
quel agent
bah moi je pensais aussi enfin c'est ça
un peu plus de sens que ça soit eu que
ça que ça soit juste parce que onze
joueurs d ou alors beaucoup de joueurs
des pays slaves et jouer ça du coup il
faudra que je que je regarde est-ce que
je peux trouver sa soeur vicky veilleux
ou ou tuer sinon tu peux faire comme
exxon hawaii nous pourrons pas vu de
votre vidéo de wikipédia 28 mai ses
ressources son article c'était une fille
que nous faisons aussi retrouve ya
quelqu'un y avait un blagueur qui fait
qu'il ya juste dix neuf afro de cette
couverture
ok donc la cave et insiste pour revenir
en 7,5 salaire normal et assure aussi
c'est ça le seul coup non c'est pas le
seul coup en fait parce que c'est tout
romney hall et son temps autre mauvais
il vous reste plus que 30 secondes c'est
fou non mais ça a coincé entre la
dernière partie où il lui restait chez
pas 14 secondes entre durs et maintenant
ouais c'est une sacrée différence bon
très mauvais talent management dessous
de la foire de nono elle est en avance
au score
donc c'est ça qui grâce aux frelons mais
s'il continue comme ça salit et ça ira
pas ça ira pas pendant longtemps donc
ces six l'ordi des tests combativité
test nous pousser 6 moi personnellement
jamais embêté moi ce que je pense que
j'aurais joué ce genre de coups mais en
fait le dossier c'est qu'il ya juste fou
et le 3 est un vieux que la dame attaque
par l'adam défend ce tour sa menace de
prendre le cavadee et maintenant y aura
des ouvrages soucis à cause de ça donc
maintenant si lecavalier euros par mois
il y aura peut-être ou paie donc l
affaire at this way mais en fait c'était
pas très loin de faire [ __ ] huawei de
fait refouler 5 c'était mieux de faire
flouer 3 justement donc là c'est
vraiment ce qu'on leur dit m et du coup
là il ya ding à des français 6 suivi de
d'un produit tu es fou prend business
qui est quasiment pop
en défense la surmultipliée ok je vais
peut-être aller chercher ça en fait j'ai
cherché sous du coup ça m'intrigue blanc
trop défensive qui est idiote
d'accord mais est ce qu'ils disent
non mais parce que du coup j'ai cherché
défense l'avocat pidio mais la pluie
d'hier sur l'origine de la variante il
appelait c'est la défense orthodoxe
d'encore orthodoxe est vraiment lié aux
au pays slaves
ado non ont du coup j'ai gelé voir ça
sur moi même sur le wikipedia en anglais
les sur le wiki piqué anglais
amasser may ou continues tu n'as
vraiment d'une enfant tu nous a vraiment
des nachos ils disent que beaucoup de
grands maîtres de d'origine slave ont
aidé à populariser la théorie de cette
ouverture développé la théorie comme par
exemple la lapine à les kings bogoliubov
et 8 noir donc je sais pas où tu allé
chercher sa mère mais bon c'était
c'était une très belle très belle
histoire ce que nous en raconter mais
ouais voilà
voyons donc bon c'est s&n c'était une
très belle histoire mais il met du coup
voilà ok donc excuse pas ceci aura
peut-être qu il ya à cela n'a peut-être
assez inquiets sur la prise ou le cas
avec du temple donc à 5 salaires des
deux gagnants mais avec leur temps
oiseaux ont pas trop le nom au y avait
qu à l'épreuve des gâteaux si je fume
pour gagner là bas
ok ouais mais bon là c'est bull est
quasiment achevé pas dire grand chose de
ce que c'est normal que y ait plein de
gaffes comme la lecavalier
oh non c'est fou s'il se passe c'est
faux
comment s'appelle le monde s'est mis
slave
aucune idée
donc elle a gagné mais même en satin
faisait en inde ce qui se passe à la fin
c'était c'était juste les pieds salés et
les allées un peu n'importe où sauf
façon d'evry qui trois mois par an jean
exact mais ca trù c'était vraiment
c'était vraiment en poisson d'avril en
justice et a cru que c'était que ce
serait cool à cette baisse est très
symétriques tout ça sauf que le fouet la
paix l'autre fou n'est pas là c'est tout
c'est tellement il ya aussi du rock et
l'autre n'est pas petit rock c'était mon
amant l'analyse très très scientifique
qui ne la politique ok donc là pour
garder le sait la symétrie je pense que
c'est bien en fait de faire h4 ça et ça
évite tous les tous les trucs un peu
moche qui arrive après avoue apprécier
nord de même push ce prochain jeu 4 donc
toi faut juste que mes f6 faut repartir
avec le fou donc vaut mieux faire h 4 en
effet
adam le mari de ses miss l'accession
josh smith la veste mais n'at elle pas
mal d'appels mais tu veux mais tu les as
tu les as tu les trouves ou d'autres
tout ça dis donc t'as l'estrie qui
tourne 8 gotham chez toqué donc c'est
que femme qu'est ce qu'il ya ce mineur
ni à la légende
ok donc bon lala l'énorme aimerait bien
pouvoir faire baisser mais clairement vu
le cuir à 5 ça sera pas trop possible à
moins qu'ils arrivent afin autrui du
genre ça nous on n'y croit pas trop trop
nemo - à 508 il faut que les poussées b4
tête il peut aussi faire des trucs du
genre de 5 mais si des 5
il y aura toujours faux problème 6
manqué mes dessins ou peu de quatre
baies 5 ici vu que maintenant vu que le
cabinet partie saleh à alès les nord ou
en projet
bon à prendre au dessin c'est vrai que
ça a l'air aussi assez tentant vu que ça
a doublé bien mais je crois qu'il a eu
raison de pousser et payzac et ne pas
vraiment ce souci et 2 août sous sol
alors donc l a fait métro b 4 à monza il
vaut mieux juste bloquer la position
avec ak d'abord peut-être prendre ici un
pote pour éviter les échanges ont
d'abord pendant et après pour 10 à 4 et
après essayer de faire des trucs aux
places faire moi même nom mais je fais
pas ça la rend peu en venant jouer après
quel écran
donc elle a réfléchi réfléchi mais les
temps sont assez similaires cette fois
donc ça va encore encore à peu près
donc elle a pris et lundi seront à la
fête soit on l'a dit et le but c'est
d'être empêchés en fait de la prison des
cinq hommes et l'avant il lui suffit
juste de faire un 4 ou encore un peu me
kane même prendre ok donc elle me
doubler des piments ok c'est moi non
c'est malin et poussé à 4 donc la tête
qu'il veut faire des quatre mois au
prochain coup j'imagine que c'est sain
c'est son idée peut-être d'abord autour
autour des 1 et après coup cédé 4 bien
sûr pas des cathos sud parce qu'il ya
faut qu'on vous promet en tout cas où
peut-être reclassement vote mais sur 24
qui aurait sans doute foule g4 et des
cas ça serait plus possible à cause de
fo prend
j'ai vu que je demande à kevin décembre
mais du coup c'est bien de gotham
classement c'est cette légende des caps
à bergues
c'est bien vu c'est très bien 2
mais son temps est encore très mauvais
donc d'ailleurs au lieu de 3 alors dit
là mais bien sept pouces et le 4 est
apparemment il n'était pas possible de
francs j'imagine qu'il y avait des trucs
du genre calvet qui bouge que le port
ouais cavalli qui peuvent rouler en h2
compte du lot après les frappes donc
même en est la page de sa donc est là et
essayer de d'ouvrir cette diagonale pour
le fou home non non m3 ça marche pas
mais vous ne la fais les ok donc à quel
point je devine bien sûr c'est le seul
coup ouais euh cas c'est bien parce que
la structure des pions noirs et terrible
surtout s'ils prennent moi donc il faut
vraiment pas qu'elle prenne d'assaut
bougeant mes frères je ferais bien ce
coup là donc et donc elle essaie de
doubler leur dis dis car des cinq ici
qu'il gagne un projet énorme ceux des
cinq prises mais j'ignorais tout reprend
et après ça mais bon elle a pas fait ça
donc ça va trotter 3 hockey un tel essai
de hockey 7,4 où elle fait ça l'air
chaud
donc la tour qui rentre et peut-être
lautour aussi qu'il peut rentrer aussi
f4 f5 peu d'autres
en d3 à temps il y avait qui d'autre
donc avait un en d3 dans l'iard y avait
hier vers gotham chess cabinet kg ayew
en arctique logo soit l'arctique soit
une vidéo hockey aa gadin de roquettes
c'est agathois
ok donc où là c'est ça va être chaud
pour les blancs ça je pense que c'est
quasiment gagnons donc il est creux h va
marquer encore ce genre celui info balle
elle revient progressivement elle
revient donc qu'est-ce qui est une cause
elles reprennent par les parties
s'assoient une pause
si tu fais mon honneur il fautif en 2002
bat manon 6 super bizarre far hills qui
est banni la chaîne ou quoi super
bizarre hockey bompas apparence et une
pause
c'est bizarre parce que les partis ne
reprennent pas alors qu'il reste encore
il reste encore 20 minutes
bon bah on dirait que c'est vraiment une
pause donc bon bah du coup je vais aussi
faire une petite pause safege oriente
allons maintenant et ont repris elles
ont repris ok donc c'était juste bizarre
alors j'ai pas ce qui est arrivé
c est trop bien mais le symbole est ok
donc ça a repris web ça nous sommes par
exemple bizarre justement qu'il fasse
une pause dans son truc c'était même pas
c'était même pas la moitié gauche
savaient pas trop sont ok donc donc là
c'est une robe noire et y donc c'est
bien qu'avec le kw/h elle ne joue plus
sont des cartes c4 et ken avec son eee
museau d'un de ces deux c'est bien qu'il
ait changé de d'idées
bonsoir à jesse torride
nous allons bien nous allons bien et toi
quand comment on va dire ok donc là il
ya peut-être la prise
donc ça ça c'est normal je pense ou
alors peut-être juste faire ces trois
faire des trucs c'est ce genre de prison
ferme et je trouve que ça en plus c'est
un peu ouais pendant ces impulsions
je trouve que c'était un peu boring j'ai
oublié le mot français pour boring
ennuyeux
voilà ce genre de position peut-être f6
là pour défendre ce pion et peut-être
fou cette dame ces dames 17 et peut-être
fois je crois
ouais donc là ça m'a l'air normal pour
fo aussi soit c'est ce que je réussis
ah non en fait il ya un gros décalage
c'est pour ça c'était pour ça que qu'on
dirait que je réponds aux commentaires
ni minutes après mais en fait c'est
parce que j'y réponds aussi des objets
moi mais c'est le problème c'est que il
ya un gros décalage entre le moment où
je parle et que l'on ou le voyez donc si
je réponds à des trucs qui se sont
passés il ya dix minutes j pdg peut pas
grand chose donc aux cuma bon week end
en pièces merci pour le sobre chess lui
dit qui est
merci pour le razer du 18 bienvenue à
tous donc bon je fais moi je vais
essayer de faire le shard of mais je
crois que je peux pas le faire revue je
suis pas je suis pas modérateur donc guy
d'itv tu peux te faire ton chat aux
autres manuels comme tafer dernière fois
à c'était une bonne tradition ok tu peux
[Rires]
bon du coup alors qu'est ce qui se passe
ta détour des huit pour essayer de
mettre la pression mais c'est au plan de
jeu et donc qu'ils entendent défendre
donc quelle est la tour des huit que se
passe-t-il comment est ce que les blancs
peuvent défendre et bien en fait je
pense qu'ils peuvent pas défendre donc
il vaut mieux qu'ils attaquent ce pion
ces inquié mais seulement une défense ça
serait de faire un truc de leurs salles
non c'est pas top
donc voilà donc ça m'habite peut-être 5
4 qui peuvent à et qui peut arriver
bonsoir pascal
ah je sais pas je sais pas lire il n'y
avait pas trop de décalage en plus fier
je répondais message passe était assez
assez assez rapide moi même parce que du
coup je parlais on est aussitôt après
dans le chat et on répondait alors que
la voyant gros décalage mais je pense
que c'est juste que ma connexion un truc
du genre il doit y avoir vraiment en oui
au milieu donc ouais j'espère que demain
ça et ça ira mieux
le décalage mais bon ça va on se
comprend quand même ok donc peut-être y
acheter si lecavalier repart en f3 il y
aura peut être eu quatre vu que là le
kbc 4 aura des gros problèmes
donc ouais donc c'est aux blancs de
jouer donc c'est pour ça qu'ils étaient
qu'elle a défendu la fin du dix
cavaliers pour éviter justement de ces
problèmes là ah si ça peut se tenter
outils pour pousser bgc
j'ai senti un peu bizarre mais ouais
donc taquet vous poussez faire très
pressée de faire ça ouais est poussé
f406 peut-être faire j'ai quatre aussi
cette gamine gosse ouais j'avoue j'avoue
mais en moins non non ça va c'est un nom
assez comment ici en veux tu en géorgie
les horizons des moments assez assez
assez différent fait l'écho des collines
aux français c'est sûr meiway du coup
moi
bonsoir qui nous
donc leur peut-être poussé à 6b 5
s'avère bien salaire normal mais bon
tous ses pions là ils ont l'air fort
qu'on peut faire beaucoup de choses
bonjour super looping l'option sans 180
et je ne sais pas comment le faire en
fait si vous savez qu'on va faire dans
les derniers paramètres
je prends les conseils volontiers parce
que du coup je sais pas trop comment
comment régler sa télé quoi je peux pas
le faire pendant ce rien de tel que faut
que j'arrête après après je pourrais
changer les paramètres mais parce que du
coup je sais je sais pas vous mais moi
j'ai géré mon enseigne et après c'est
pas sympa c'est pas c'est pas dramatique
donc avant fr c'est plus possible le
caïd est enfin c'est pas si simple de
faire des progrès en passant tout le
temps qu'elle veut attaquer ce cavalier
optait qu'elle peut faire que et dès
qu'elle peut faire bouger sa langue au
site offre aux mets non c'est bien on en
est là elle a loupé il y avait quelques
faits 5.1 millions à ses 3 - 2 % oui ok
parce que crée la loupe et en gros
traits qui alla alors bon avec avec le
temps là c'est plus tout ça c'est joué
autant ça va pas jouer l'apaisement
ça va pas du dos à la position ça c'est
sûr ok ouhlala donc la nana a perdu
alors qu'elle avait au moins trois
semaines avait un gros avantage là mais
elle a quand même perdu autant donc il
lui suffisait de faire banda match 5
suivi de fou j'estime qu'en fait elle
aurait une très très bonne position
bon bah du coup du coup sûr les formes
faute de quoi on pose à il va avoir les
nerfs nana je pense est là il accepte
pas la leur match je pense qu'elle
n'accepte pas parce que d'ailleurs c'est
la première fois que je vois que y ait
autant de pauses entre entre chaque
partie
mais je pense que dioukoul a généré
l'acceptent pas d'habitude les parties
elles s'enchaînent dans l'homme aussitôt
qu'une partie et finir aussi tout ça ça
reprend la nouvelle parce que c'est les
joueuses elle même qui décide c'est les
joueuses des mêmes qui défie toute
puissance des 1 8 me du coup elles
doivent en l'honneur alors qu'ils
resteront 11 minutes au à la au times ça
veut dire c'est pas du tout fini sa mort
ok bon ba ba du coup on attend on attend
que les cdci de hockey elle a enfin
accepté ok donc ok donc d4 d425
ouais c'est une système de longues et
âpres pas qu'on voit ça ici
ok donc sur d'armes ces deux il ya foule
il faut être simple c'est assez connu
wow f5 mais assure sera possible de
prendre parce que il y avait dans mon
premier 2 donc ça court ça qu'elle a
fait dans l'océan donc ici bon ça c'est
typique mais c'était pas très bien en
fait de faire d'un de ces deux c'est
beaucoup mieux de prendre de prendre
mais si je le crois cela s'est produit
si on ne prenait pas top up ok ok c'est
assez l'attention le note la tempe
normal
ok attendant fou que j'active ou mieux
que je désactive la l'attention du coup
je vois pas ce que ça veut dire la
latence faire un essai pour conclure que
je connais donc ouais donc il faut que
je mette la tension on attend la danse
normal alors du coup et après
j'essaierai de le faire donc bon là ça a
pas l'air toi tu à te faut faire qu'à
veiller fin qu'a vu le 3 mai de la
pression lors peut-être wet j'allais
dire feuillage permet d'adapter [ __ ]
de sa demande ça n'empêche ce cavalli
fait absolument rien en d2 absolument
rien
donc voilà les pièces de blanche c'est
terrible c'est un cauchemar
on ne vous fait rien le cahier fait rien
ce cavalier fait quasiment rien aussi
c'est vraiment terrible
bon ce cas y quoi payer quand même venir
re 5 mais bon c'est la dame ou s'il fait
rien et tours sont par lille et ça c'est
horriblement je pense quand un truc du
genre fu fu d1 pour mettre le feu dans
ces deux ça serait pas mal
ou alors mettre le cavalier comme ça en
rétro hockey ou ou sinon comment elle a
fait passer les camélias
à faut activer activer la latence faible
ok ok j'ai compris
merci du couple merci pour pour l'info
merci thestreet
à la latence et le délai communication
avec le serveur ok j'ai compris donc
j'espère c'est que ça va pas faire des
trucs qu'on avec ma connexion si c'est
plus rapide que ça est mauvais avec moi
avec mon élection je ne sais pas
sélectionnez stream bons amis
est ce qu'il faut que je fasse a dance
with chaussures ou sur obs sur twin j'ai
juste le le service est là la clé de ce
trimestre dont j'ai rien d'autre mais en
plus j'ai écrit ça angers ça en anglais
donc est ce que en anglais ça veut dire
stream dit lei est-ce que c'est suit mme
bligh la danse
ok ok cas j'ai compris
ok bonne explication merci pour l'info
nous bon ouais mais bon goût j'essayerai
de changer ça je vais regarder aussi des
tutoriels là dessus parce que j'ai pas
trouvé en fait que tu m'as envoyé juste
et sûrement sur suisse est à parme
c'est à paris donc quoi je regarde ses
droits faurecia sion gc ca
ok donc là il ya peut-être des db4 il
m'arrivait way à 5 ou 6 5 mais 4 à le
tableau de bord de twitch ok ok j'ai
compris
meslier mais méfiance parce que ce que
sa part à bord avec toute l'équipe parce
que hier ça marchait bien
hier il n'y avait pas un gros délais
alors qu'aujourd'hui un délai dont je
pense que twitchell n'a pas changé grand
chose
pas entre hier et aujourd'hui je pense
que rien n'a changé donc
donc je pense pas que ça soit que ça
soit ça le truc fort je pense que c'est
juste dû à ma connexion que ya un gourou
délais a dit laisser latence hockey
compris alors
moi j'ai ok ok ouais ok c'est logique
c'est le lit
bon alors que se passe-t-il ici donc là
je pense que ces gros avantage pour les
noirs surtout plat le fouillent défend
bien le pian donc il ya un gros payant
pas ses concurrents passaient bien
avancé donc on dirait que croche revient
elle revient vraiment donc là sûr
qu'elles surgissent ici on rappeler qu'à
l'étranger 6 donc il vaut mieux à mon
avis défendre avec la peau il faut
vraiment qu'elle fasse un ouais c'est ce
qu'elle a fait
ouais ok ouais ok je reviendrai sans
merci mr c'est pour les pour les
conseils alors il n'y a pas de française
en son nom mais il y aura regardé ya
quand même des gens qui sont bien aimé
par les français comme par exemple
catherine l'agglo qui aie aie elle avait
beaucoup de fans fous de beaucoup de
supporters dans le dans le jazz
quand elle joue est évoqué moi je crois
que c'est tout en fait je crois que
c'est vraiment juste elle aussi wind a
été et est bienvenue mais je crois mais
bon on a vu que je vais faire je vais le
lien car entre autres l'une l'une contre
l'autre
ouais donc donc c'était plutôt à la
matité plutôt pour paulino donc aux
attendes il s'est passé quoi s'est passé
comme elle est traitée par un crime en
est du coup et surtout gagnante
totalement gagnante
ouais non classées elles arrivent pas
gagné 3 secondes à la pendule c'est que
faut arrêter déjà enfin si la troupe je
dis ça mais ça se trouvait ça me va elle
va vous loupé sa troupe et de genres f7
way et va pousser ses avions
donc elle a gagné elle a gagné et il
reste deux minutes
donc après cette partie ont normalement
ça sera fini elle sera l'heure de passer
en direct aux eaux bullet c'est déjà
l'heure du bellâtre c'est faux ça c'est
dit alors des bulles est donc c'était
demi à quatre et demi donc c'était pas
des parties très propre mais karine donc
c'est bon c'est ce qu'il faut gagner ça
sert pas à grand chose de faire des
supers partie si on gagne pas donc voilà
elle marque des points on manque donc
c'est bien c'est bien merci à thiès
assez sympa bah ouais du coup c'est vrai
que c'est on peut pas trop parler des
coûts en direct mais vous pouvez quand
même voir les parties avec cinq minutes
de retard
- heureusement mais oui j'espère que la
prochaine fois ça y est un peu mieux bon
bah du coup bonne soirée lors montsouris
et oui je la serre est de régler sans
donc là c'est un dernier à partir les
bullet et j'ai vraiment hâte de voir si
elle est ce que c'est ce que ça a donné
un but let's se mettre à semmar au barça
je dirais que c'est un smash si c'est
vraiment le moins que si cons et qu'on
ait vu pendant les coups sont vraiment
pas très sains
oui pas très précis disons que la
plupart des matches j'avais regardé n
joué la plupart du temps les côté de
l'ordi surtout les premiers marcheurs
par exemple la même le match de
stepanova ou alors y en avait d'autres
jeunes à y en avait beaucoup d'autres
qui avaient vraiment bien joué par
exemple même lagnes euros à mon goût
nina cède à vraiment de la bonne qualité
mais ce match 6-7 pas et je vous ferai
pas vraiment très précises donc ouais
donc à biabou ya beaucoup de gars fait
aussi beaucoup de coups assez agressif
qui sont intéressants d'un point de vue
pratique mais coordin
comment va donc céder style de jeu un
peu différent
donc j'ai l'impression que le style des
deux joueuses à part surtout onana je
pensais un peu plus agressif donc elle a
un esprit très sains
ouais très tactique elle affichait pas
trop stratégiquement dirais enfin ça
c'est juste mon opinion vu que à prêter
que c'est pas si c'est pas totalement
exact mais d'après ce que j'ai vu
on dirait que c'est le cas donc là elle
menace ok donc là il y avait peut-être
eu cinq ou six qui est intéressant mais
l'a pas fait donc ouais donc là les
noirs peut-être pu sortir saddam normes
certains ça donne ça serait très
mauvaise à cause de cavalli un calice et
4 je pense atteindra 5 milliards jusqu'à
et c4 donc juste dames c'est sale c'est
bien pour faire tout retour des 8 quai
les dessins aussi
ouais donc là je pense que c'est déjà un
petit avantage pour les normes qu'il y
aurait peut-être des trucs du genre ça
aussi le pouls le fou pour revenir
contrôler ces diagonales
il y aura beaucoup de menaces mon avis
voilà des d'ailleurs couach c'est une
joueuse américaine ne l'est pas c'est
pas une joueuse de l'est
donc elle elle se bat contre est
justement celle afficheur de nos jours
mais oui si on retrouve les pays de l'ex
union soviétique sont très très fort aux
achats qu'ils ont vraiment une longue
tradition
une autre tradition et chicken point
d'ailleurs quasiment tous et je vous ai
jamais dans les pays de l'est mais oui
parce qu'ils apprennent ça qu'on va
quand ils sont petits offrent au même
niveau qu'en fin quand les français
affrontent ils apprennent et jeux de
cartes alors ruiz à prendre mais le jeu
des chats qui s'est assez assez comment
c'est rare de trouver des fins d des
gens dansent un tarage qui connaissent
pas les excès qu il est jeune il peut
n'y connaissent pas ils connaissent pas
parce que ça commence à se perdre cette
tradition mais mais les vieux enfin niko
nasu 16h avec bien sûr
donc peut-être faire dès ce jour à 6b
singes mais le fameux section pouces
bessin et le plan c 6 va tomber c'est
pas top
peut-être faire à 5 aux commerçants que
ça s'avérait juste à empêcher b4 cette
fois ça n'a pas grand chose à laquelle
17 ça ça attaque le plus récent que
c'est pas mal
elle nous a aidé à attaquer le curé 5
mais bon je pense qu'elle peut quand
même assez défendre assez facilement à
tous 1
et juste pour un petit rappel ça sert la
dernière partie on sait la dernière
partie après ça sera l'heure du bullet
donc le bullet ça va être vraiment sympa
à voir
ouais bah c'est un défi bly les petits
il peut pas prendre tout seul il faut
qu'elles aient quand ils leur apprennent
que ça soit les parents gaza soit une
école où alors bah oui ça vient d'une
heure d'une influence extérieure eux ils
peuvent pas juste décidé de jouer aux
échecs donc si les parents connaissent
en général ils vont apprendre aux
enfants ou alors un peu à qui ils
peuvent eux aussi décidé que les échecs
se fait pas il vaut mieux de ne pas ne
pas connaître et ne pas leur apprendre c
arrive souvent d'ailleurs d'aller grand
maître les super grand maître par
exemple même kasparov crois qu'il a
choisi de ne pas faire jouer aux échecs
c'est à ses enfants
il n'aura pas appris à vue parce qu'il
veut je vous dis veut justement pas
qu'il soit dans ce monde là donc ouais
ah non mais c'est sûr mais c'est sur les
français et séisme en panne ou même le
même un la même école soviétique disons
pour les échecs ça c'est sûr
en plus ils ont une longue histoire
d'aborder des godillots des gros titres
donc ça aide aussi à motiver les jeunes
à commencer parce que ça lors d'une
phase à leur donnant un objectif alors
que les français m'ont yao bien sûr on
and on a des formes joueurs mais on n'a
pas fait ça cette même cette même
histoire
weight cette même histoire bonsoir
julien je vais très bien et toi mais
cela ça faire de mal aller pour irina
crunch à nouveau droit d'un mètre d'eux
peut-être suivi de tours h4 ouais donc
au bal a perdu autant c'est fou ça il a
perdu autant
nadal a perdu autant dans une police ont
archi gagnant alors qu'il aurait pu tout
et elle aurait pu faire qu'est première
c1 qu'elle aurait pu faire absolument
tout ce qu'elle veut genre cavaliers
trois cas y allez prenez 5 à 8 des deux
mêmes
tous rêvent de clara peut vraiment tout
faire même roitg set était tout un login
ans mais elle a perdu autant c'est très
dommage c'est très dommage alors licour
d'échec je les donne en tout ligne ou
moins en face enfin jusqu'à 10 en 2000
même du 1100 jeunes gens donnent c'est
même plus que ça c'est fait ça sans
peuvent être un peu bizarre vu que moi
même j'ai des 1120 165 à remédier aux
coûts à tous les niveaux enfin je pense
que mes élèves les plus à moi les plus
faibles dix ans ils ont 6 ans et l'autre
sur jesse d'accord sur ce point est lié
plusieurs pays dont environ 1900 1902
mille journées j'ai déjà eu il fait et
2005 mais non en ce moment j'en ai pas à
exclure les échecs sont considérés comme
on dit sport bah oui en fait ils le sont
mais il ya beaucoup d'efforts joueurs
par exemple nakamura ou alors
ou alors d'autres d'autres disent on
reste avait faite de tweed qui ont fait
partie de deux teams noailles espot donc
oui l'annoncé considéré comme lui se
porte maintenant clairement ils ont
mérité leur place là bas
bon bah du coup c'est la pause donc je
vais moi aussi faire une toute petite
pause et je reviens tout de suite pour
le bullet alors à tout de suite
je suis de retour alors ça a repris donc
il sera en soit la première partie du
lot
donc voilà ce qui se passe
donc c'était c'est la même que de
toujours qui je suis l'ours est ouvert
sur la scène marrant d'ailleurs mais
cette fois elle a pris donc récemment on
dirait qu'elle prend avec le fond plutôt
que faire cailler 2 donc la changer en
que sa stratégie et voilà c'est mais
c'est cela qu'ils ont la même vache à
quoi je pense que je pense que c'est
vrai et c'est presque la même
on a déjà avec g3 opus nattawut sapin
enfin je pense vraiment deux fois on a
vu ça donc est ce que les cours que je
donne sont gratuits bien sûr bien sûr
j'ai que ça à faire le grand show ce
soir à paris en fait non je ne suis pas
trop je ne suis pas trop je devrais je
sais mais je ne suis pas du coup si vous
savez en fait qu'ils sont nés qui sont
les gagnants j'aimerais bien savoir on
peut être qui sait qu'ils gagnent qu'est
-ce qui y mènent le train
bon mais il faudrait vraiment qu'elle
arrête de jouer cette ligne mon annonce
c'est ça n'a pas de sens c'est pas bon
cette ligne plus il y aura des cas les
preuves et rohff
ça rend pas chez eux ce qu'elle fait en
plus je joue il a même une ligne à
chaque fois c'est super bizarre surtout
minutes à chaque fois n'a pas une bonne
position
ok donc là-bas faut aussi défendre un
pion même temps de fou dégâts pour
attaquer des f 5 qui arrive aussi parce
que le fou et à malpassé ok donc elle a
bien bougés ça c'est bien
alors donc la diagonale elle peut être
faible et c'est quasiment fermé là d'un
attentat un temps est là et la caf et la
fausse aussi sa grosse gaffe en plus
elle pouvait faire comprendre à 5 et fr
d'un g5 et gagner comme ça grâce à une
pince à et à l'échec ouais mais il a pas
fait du poulet y ait la guerre film non
mais c'est fou c'est parti améliorer ce
3 ans et pour sa médaille mais non les
blancs sont gagnants parce que parce
qu'elle va réussir à faire ça à prendre
neuf ou non mais c'est pas si c'est
incroyable c'est incroyable c'est parti
en saas décédera autant mais même si les
gagnants tout au niveau de la pollution
saveurs à venir passer lui reste trois
secondes
donc ok donc là elle a réussi à gagner
quand même ouais à la gagne c'est bien
ça bien cette fois et la haine ne
méritait quand même fait pas vraiment
mais c'était vraiment bizarre ce qui
arrive ok donc là c'est assez symétrie
sauf qu'il ya un pion clé d'or
finalement elle se sera vraiment très
symétrique du coût exact exactement
symétrique
donc ça va super vite en plus non je
n'aurais les prises prendre 5 c'est un
très mauvais choix parce qu'il y aura
des dames 1 h 5 il faut prendre un set
donc il vaut mieux garder garder ce
camion s inquiète pas répondre kelly est
simple ça peut se tenter parce que sur
fou prend on peut reprendre et à bord en
avant postes en quatre
grâce aux documents qui seront là qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire c'est catherine
ps1 et bouquets pour préparer ses cadres
mais c'était pas d'un césar et pouvait
faire ces quatre total enfin directement
je pense
donc la sueur sur fou prend il y aura
peut-être un v6 le pur a eu des cats
sera très faible tant pis si j'aime bien
ici après peut-être qu'avec des six
essais de rentrer avec 5
donc là le redis dit tu viens [ __ ] en
racheta tiki et +7 pour les blancs ici
pour prendre au hockey l'a pas fait elle
n'a pas vu non plus et s était assez
facile parce que fo prend achète pour
apprendre d'un match 5 qui avait jugé
ici c'était sec et c'était fini
mais bon elle l'a pas vu donc donc c'est
bien pour la norme en plus maintenant la
russie a fermé la position va pas se
faire qu'avec des six qu'avait lieu 4
donc bon là essayer de remettre en
camion est simple c'est bien vu parce
que sinon il y aurait eu dame m dames et
si ce n'est bien sûr pas réussi à 4,5
donc ok donc elle essaie de faire
décaler yapi j'imagine pour essayer des
jeux pc place en plus ukr 6 défend la
case d'hachette
pas fumer valeur au attendant il ya
peine maths et ses prix en maths elle
s'est pris un masque wahou c'est faux ok
bon alors j'aime bien ça va en fait
combien de temps il lui restait voici à
trouver là fait un prix move je vais pas
ce qui arrive c'est fou bon alors pour
mon éducation et chiliennes
alors tout d'abord je me suis inscrit à
un club donc ils m'ont appris les règles
du jeu là bas et après progressivement
j'ai envie de changer de club et après
enfin tu allais au club de deux enfants
du coup c'est vraiment celui-là oui j'ai
commencé à vraiment apprendre c'est ça
le grand maître enfin maintenant il est
grand mais froid mais au moment où il
donnait des cours il décemment maître
international alex hayes et charnue chez
lui qui me donnait il me donnait des
cours quand j'étais petit et grâce à lui
j'ai vraiment bien bossé
tu possèdes la tactique et surtout la
tactique en fait je bossais mais ça me
plaisait bien aussi un peu d'ouverture
et après après du coup je dois dire à
d'autres clubs mais un oui j'ai vu dit
des très bons entraîneurs à chaque fois
mon coup c'est comme ça que beaucoup
jugeaient que j'ai commencé à ma
carrière entre guillemets mais aussi
l'homme et par an en option peut aider
parce que du coup je bossais aussi à la
maison mais ça c'était son grand que
j'étais tout petit
après un prêt géant peut on peut arrêter
le rythme là je parlais quand j'avais 6
à 6 à 10 en dix ans peut-être moins onze
ans mais après j'ai un peu arrêté de
bosser régulièrement
donc ok donc revenons à ça donc
peut-être ya faut prendre des quatre sa
marche absolument pas utile un faux
problème 5
enfin peut-être 6pour pour attaquer le
cabellec avec la dame ou alors c'est que
ça là encore plus fort et 5
que se passe-t-il sur cinq
moi je sais pas s'il se passait ce re5
ont fait ça va leur forme et leur
dilemme est bas aura peut-être qu il y
avait 26 ans sur sa sur cinq peut-être
un ancien mais non donc j'invite des de
mettre sa haine pour savoir leur dirai
laisse pas jouer donc ok continue doctor
who you for me ok les résultats
d'aujourd'hui grand chef tour suilhard
ok ok donc ils sont tous âges et à
aiguiser khune pour à rognan suis leur
sauve ok ok ok a donc maintenant sur une
heure puis 2 4 points mbl 3.2.1 ok il ya
des points qui convoque ito en double ça
veut dire rosa
ok alors que se passe-t-il donc avant
c'était petit avantage fois les normes
énoncées petit avantage pour les blancs
j'imagine que ce plan des singes va
bientôt tomber way simplement maintenant
bas qu'il ya peut-être tour pc suivi de
cavaillé c3 où il fait figure est exact
exact mais bon j'aurais ça m'aurait pas
non plus des plus d'être la fille de
castor mails même si même si je jouais
pas vous échec
ah oui on peut mais bah oui du coup ça
manque plus oublié mais maintenant ça me
cimon plus juste à un moment donné ça
monsieur voulez vous bien maintenant
j'aime beaucoup ça j'ai repris
d'ailleurs je suis assez mais je suis
assez motivés par les échecs heures à
nouveau jeu je prends assez beaucoup de
plaisir à jouer donc
donc oui mais non je suis bien motivé
mais pendant un moment donné je l'étais
plus plu du tout
donc na na 6 6 9 et demi quand sessegnon
16,5 au score mais c'est peut-être
possible encore pour irina de se
rattraper parce qu'elle a pris des
points récemment
donc ouais sait jamais donc là il reste
13 et 13 minutes en 14 min 14 minutes et
voyons voir ce qui se passera tout est
possible encore pour vous riquez rappelé
qu'elle peut encore encore sauver sa
donc là moi personnellement je ferais
bien un truc comme cahier des cartes
mais je pense que c'est super beau mais
parce qu'ils jouent ça me donnerait des
plans d'oubli voilà ça serait mon gâteau
qu'est donc plutôt des trucs du genre ça
ou alors est ce si sûr mal à jouer ça a
l'air pas mal
bon là ça leur salaire très difficile
succès du budget
ça ça change à tous les coups ce qui se
passe mais ben ouais là là salaire
salaire difficile du côté des noirs je
pense que c'est plutôt les blancs qui
vont gagner ça surtout peut-être faire
des trucs du genre ça repousser ces
quatre peut-être possible juste prendre
et c'est de gagner la finale avant
l'entrée prendre ici peuvent être
échangés les dames est rentré la tour e
set ça a l'air pas mal
obame en général à jean j'entraîne pas
vraiment les petits en fait j'ai
seulement 1 1 ou 2 en fait ouais j'ai
deux élèves en fait ils sont jeunes a
mais en général j'entends j'entraîne que
tous les adultes donc mais j'aime bien
les deux faces du coup vu que j'ai pas
trop d'excellence en traîner les petits
c'est super intéressant pour moi de le
faire donc mais bon en tennis adultes
enfin j'aime bien les deux en fait
j'aime bien les deux mais c'est ça et
c'est surtout les adieux qui me contacte
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai plutôt des
élèves des élèves adultes
mais j'ai agi en géant petits de 7 ans
aussi un petit 7 ans il y est romand
j'aime bien avoir les cours à écueil il
est drôle il aime bien ils adorent la
tactique
ok du coup à irin a encore gagné on a
gagné donc le score se rapproche à y
reste plus que 10 minutes et 50 secondes
donc ça ça risque d'être un pion isolé
bientôt sur l'ouest et le reprendre sa
tournée vers tokyo et isolées
donc en général alors là je pense que
pousser ça ça serait bien pour elle
ouais c'est ce qu'elle a fait le plus
dur en jouant avec si peu de temps quels
sont les pièges à éviter alors si tu as
vraiment peu de temps c'est bien de
faire des échanges et surtout pas faire
des sacrifices
si tu fais des sacrifices c'est
tellement facile de fernand de mal
calculé will de flux dire c'est que tu
as qu'une minute wayne exact exact ouais
mais tout est difficile quand il reste
quasiment pas tant
arias peut-être ce qui a valu à 4 m et
la dame la dame se cache
donc ça bien sûr la tour n'était pas
prenable parce qu'il y avait mes preuves
à 4
donc ça affecte un pour les blancs ça ça
vraiment pas l'air top
ouais donc là bon ça va vite j'essaie de
calculer mais ça mais ça va très vite
donc ouais ok donc là ouais vous pouvez
3 c'est bien vu c'est bien vu j'ai
l'impression qu'au b3 à gagner en plus
là au lieu de fo prend p 4 vous prendrez
15,6 à viser juste b3 c'est également
parce que surtout reprend il y avait
foule en d4
mais bon elle l'a pas vu donc là c'est
une finale je pense que c'est un
avantage voire même fou cavalli
contrefous surtout que là les pions sur
ds sur les deux côtés je pense que ça
aille très bien pour lui pour les plans
et la structure de plomb et un peu
légèrement favorable au noir aussi
bon alors ça dépend en fait j'ai un peut
de tout j'ai des élèves qui viennent
d'un peu de commencer à jouer
ils viennent ils ont appris en fait
quand ils ont découvert qu'une
guinguette par exemple ils ont commencé
à jouer à ce moment là où il y en a
d'autres qui vous depuis très longtemps
qu'ils sont très sérieux et qui ont vu
d'autres coaches aussi et qui sont
vraiment motivés à progresser j'ai eu
vraiment on peut tous en fait j'ai
vraiment de tout yona dès qu'ils veulent
vraiment faire des compètes aussi qu'ils
veulent vraiment et qui sont vraiment
super motivé il y en a des qui jouent
vraiment juste pour battre le voisin par
une le voisin fait par exemple donc dmb
vite pour l'échangé les dames donc b3
donc lui s'en fiche d'impro f4 ça serait
pas un très bon choix parce que sur fou
prend le fousseret très actif il y
aurait des petites rues que lors vous
êtes peut-être vous disent ce genre de
chose au décide peut-être tenté pour
empêcher ça je pense que l'échangé dame
serait quand même en leur faveur des
blancs et surtout cahier 1 4 qui arrive
c'est assez c'est pas top ça
ok
ouais mais du coup c'est quand même gros
avantage pour les blancs semblent je
pense à mon quoi quoi quoi que non c'est
pas tant un gros avantage que ça c'est
un petit avantage france
mais bon la tour qui va rentrer sur la
7ème tour ces deux peut-être je vais te
fous ces 5
ouais ça l'a pas mal
ben disons que je ne recherche pas
activement mais s'il y en a qui se
présente oui j'ai eu mon planning n'est
pas encore plein
donc j'ai prend f100 il faudrait pas à
reprendre avec le roi parce que re4 donc
on sera obligé de reprendre avec le pion
plutôt bon il ya le pion aux quilles en
l'air fun donc c'est bien qu'elle
défende parce que sinon il y aurait des
soucis le temps le temps ça sera quoi
elle a perdu autant encore elle a perdu
tellement de partis autant maintenant
c'est sympa et il reste plus que moins
de monde ça monte d'ailleurs moins deux
salons de jeu et après ça sera ça sera
vraiment décisif ça
le score est tellement proches je suis
donc si la trouvent elles vont continuer
à jouer les uns ni taiwo x faut vraiment
que nana elle marque là pour avoir une
chance de le gagner sans jouer le temps
le temps additionnel
ouais donc c'est un peu bizarre qui est
donnée sion valais muet c'est de
défendre je pense mais bon c'était pas
si c'est un peu l'effet du truc genre
qu'avait ebay on n'a pas trop envie de
faire ça ça c'est sûr donc c'est assez
simple jours jouant peut-être flou à 6
et 7 pouces et les loups moi je
pousserai bien à paris ah non
j'allais dire absolument non je vais
dire qu'à la fossette jusqu'à l'épreuve
ok donc c'est difficile quand même de
deux trous et envie de progresser parce
que des cas on pourra jamais le faire et
puis c'est très bien contrôlé à cinq ou
six est bien contrôlée donc c'est pas si
simple je pense que là c'est quand même
autre gros avantage pour les noirs
des mots qu'elle a échangé ouais bon
choix je pense des cats et bien ouais ok
donc maintenant elle a une faiblesse à
attaquer heureux alex et bonjour web it
donc ouais c'est le sait bien c'est là
qu'elle est une faiblesse qu'elle peut
attaquer peut faire des dames de d2 ou
si tu essaies de faire f4 bon appareil
simple parce que tu ressens tu auras des
cinq il ya plus de sa place mais au
moins essayé d'attaquer ça comme ça
d'affaires yves 3 pour protéger
donc là il ya quand même beaucoup de
beaucoup de contres jeu beaucoup de
chance peut-être des trucs du genre ça
qu'on essaie de faire des menaces
ouais ça c'est bien vu aussi pour
essayer de rentrer en c3 bon échange de
damous et d'échangé d'un jeu je pense
pas que c'est en la faveur des noirs
là ils sont rompus perdu leur avantage
parce qu'ils avaient quand même belle
belle belle initiative
le fait d'avoir échangé d'homme je pense
pas que ça donne beaucoup attendent dans
l'histoire c'est qu'aulas pourquoi elle
a fait ça pour la pape et caillassent 5
mais c'est fou ce qui lui restait trois
ans c'est pourquoi non mais cette fois
il a juste donné une pièce là juste
donner une pièce pour rien et maintenant
ça va être père peines à la libye d'être
les bulles est bon c'est un peu d'aidé
comédie c'est la tragi-comédie
alors du coup ils resteront longtemps il
reste plus que à moins d'une minute donc
ça risque d'être la dernière partie sera
donc cette partie sera la partie
décisive
il faut vraiment queen and aliens pour
pouvoir éviter les uns leur âge ou leur
allongement
salut françois
ok alors c'est très fermé tout ça mons
hainaut je connais pas le nom en france
et un peu mieux en anglais ses kings and
and attack
je connais vraiment pas bon français
d'ailleurs si vous connaissez mon titre
sonne je serais intéressé de la femme ok
du coup là on essaye de pousser les
pions
ça a l'air bien pour les noirs en plus
ils peuvent passer le cavalier peut-être
y at-il un dicastère aussi ses trois
occupants des trois peut être attaqué on
peut aussi essayer de prendre avantage
de la colombe et mettre le foulard peut
être essayer de faire des trucs du genre
ça ça peut être cool
bah ce sa fille glisse donc pas si on
prend avec l'option et après quoi ok
donc l'a pas fait mais je pense que si
elle reprendrai s'ils apprenaient après
qu'elles faisaient food et si ça allait
je pense qu'il n'y avait pas vraiment de
boîtes de problème donc bon ahmed
boukous irina khromacheva gagner alors
donc savoir nos journaleux temps vu que
les scores seront à nouveau à ex-aequo
mais quoi que ce n'est pas encore fini
tout peut encore arriver
as tu sais c'est normal
attaquer c'est un dialogue est donc ça
pareil ok c'est ok bah merci du coup
pouvoir pour la peau
et en trad absolument à la détruire
mais bon avec ce temps là tout peut
arriver
cette attaque est vraiment très très
dangereuse
ces warrants les budget à regarder ça va
tellement vite donc bon là il suffit
juste de pousser les pions sont des
vrais gagnants facilement le patro de
science de défense fait surtout avec le
temps qu'elle a fauqué la fasse tomber
c'est tout toi as is ok donc là on a la
russie est pas stoppé la danse à
l'hôpital il ya l'option qui arrive
on fout de la gueule la tour est à fond
mais c'est ok c'était marrant ça ok donc
bon ça c'est totalement gagnant mais
seulement parce qu'il ya toujours en
l'air qui était qu'ils étaient en prison
peu dans peu dans trois groupes ne l'a
pas pris
donc ok donc ça coince ça continue alors
donc le temps vient de s'écouler mais
c'est curieux non
il faut quand même continué vu que le
bouclage et son ami québécois
donc il faut qu'il y ait au plus d'une
pour elle on arrêtait ses besoins elles
ont arrêté sept suspects remis à franck
est donc il faut qu'il y ait une
différence de plus d'enfants pour gagner
pour une d'entre elles lors guen donc là
je pense qu'il y aura une pause
peut-être et après ça va reprendre
c'était ça la série des partages c'est
le départage du coup vous pensez que qui
va gagner alors c'est quoi les
pronostics dans le chat alors
ok non je pense y aurait une petite
pause et après ça va reprendre du coup
bon bah du coup je serai de retour quand
on regarde ça va reprendre
[Musique]
ok non ça a repris donc vu que c'est du
bullet ça va super vite saison déjà fait
30 coups donc voilà ce qui se passe donc
là je pense que ça devrait faire partie
des sites décisive si on la gagne
je pense qu'elle va gagner le match si
la troupe sa dernière non sa part la
dernière est bon bien jouer vingtaine de
je pense qu'elles vont jouer pendant les
25 minutes vu que l'ail le times aurait
eu des flambées jusqu'à 25 ou peut-être
que peut-être que c'est vraiment la
dernière
désolé d'als j'espère que théoriquement
bien ça reste une musique un peu
flippante
j'avoue
donc ce qui peut se passer c'est oui
petit rock peut-être la présence et si
c'est après ok donc je veux pas faire ça
ouais mais pas les souffrances et si je
pense parce que là il le plus on était
super fermement ces six ans plus tard et
police
du coup il ya un pion de l'est en d4
je passe et c'est bien pour aller voir
enfin d'apprendre des salaires bien
créons déjà fait être en partie fait
sept enfants
bon du coup cette finale je pense que
c'est les a fermés pour les noirs à
cause de la structure de caen ça s'est
un peu plus ça c'est un peu mieux du
coup que avant un îlot un des quatre et
ses trois fins ya plus de chance mais
euh ouais ici il alourdit n'aime pas
être simple il dit que f5 vu que ça
donne à cazaux 5 je pense et ça enlève
les possibilités du lot de sang et qu'il
aime pas qu il dit que c'est un
glissement du mix à égal
c'est une musique de combat
bon là personnellement je préférerais
les noix m mais à non pourquoi peut-être
pas ya peut-être des cavaliers 4 kgs au
10 mai si on fait ça il y aura peut-être
whaou à b4 donc ouais mais ça on y
croise et 2 se défend bien c'est de
blizzard femmes échangent et le fou
contre le cahier c'était assez bizarre
cavaillé f 7 un os
irina a perdu autant cavaillé cette
lourde il s'est totalement genk fc 3
bougez cavaillé prendre après trois des
quatre pays dit que c'est gagnera bah
oui normal parce qu'on va prendre
l'avion à un pack ouais il y aura jamais
de pousser f4 vu comment on est assez
proches
donc là elles ne reprennent pas donc
s'ils retrouvent c'est vraiment la
dernière partie si je trouve que c'est
fini vu qu'elle ne reprenne pop
c'est peut-être la fin je vais aller
voir sur fait ce qu'il dit sur sur pièce
sur la caisse comme principal
abbas était fini c'est fini du coup à
nana a gagné 13 13 me contre 17 me abbas
et gaulle alors c'est cool donc nadal a
réussi à gagner donc c'est la fin c'est
la fin annoncée pas la fin attends c'est
pas la fin mai à temps mais dans les
commentaires ici ces centres à dire ça à
la fin et après la joie qu'il qu'ils ont
encore repris une partie à temps du coup
du coup c'est quoi la voilà à temps mais
fois ils font du 5 rue du lot soit j'ai
des problèmes soient elles ont fait
repris une partie est lancée en train de
juger du sérieux +2 ou alors j'ai juste
ou alors je suis en train de délirer à
temps mais je suis en train de délirer
là ou quoi bon ça doit pas faire partie
du match et a trouvé jours et je veux
juste juste pour le plaisir
bon ok c'est super bizarre mais bon le
match et finir le match est fini
officiellement fléché absolument pas
deux fois soit en train de jouer en plus
du salon plus de cinq ans
mais c'est fini c'est vers l'âge ou
juste pour le fameux et je vous
clairement juste pour la femme du coup
bon ça c'est le saas et le résultat
final c'était très ennemis contre
désigné en la faveur de nos n'a donc bon
je vais juste vous mettre ça c'est le
sas elle les appariements donc ça
ah bah non moment qu'on n'est pas ok
donc j'étais en train de dire donc les
appariements de demain ça sera entre la
chinoise lighting grille est là l'indien
mahesh a dit donc voilà ça sera ça
serait ça et voilà donc leurs pattes en
jeu quand même vous dire l'heure